Hello?
Hallo?
Ah, fremd ist abend, sehr gut.
Nice.
Mal gucken, schon jemand da?
Warte mal funktioniert das jetzt überhaupt?
Moment.
Ah, funktioniert, ja. Nice. Sehr schön.
Hallo Leute.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich bin gerade dabei, meinen Rechner zu übertakken,
meinen neuen zumindest mal auszuprobieren, was da, was geht.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, das können wir einfach im Livestream machen.
Ähm, die Sache ist nur die.
Ich hab das jetzt an meine Capturecard angeschlossen, meinen zweiten Rechner.
Und ich glaube, ich hab da ein bisschen Verzögerung drin.
Die Desktopmusik ist zu laut.
So, und ähm, ich, ich weiß nicht, ob das halbwegs passt, weil die, wenn ich über die Capturecard aufnehme,
dann hab ich natürlich Verzögerung drin.
Und wenn ich dann was sage und das zu sehr verzögert ist, dann kann das sein, dass man überhaupt nicht durchblickt, was ich eigentlich will.
Muss aber gucken, ob das klappt, ob das funktioniert.
Ihr müsst ja mal sagen, ob so Musik und so, ob das alles passt, Lautstärke von mir, Hintergrund, Gedudel und alles in der Richtung.
Hier, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Also ich würde sagen, ich zeige euch erstmal das BIOS, weil wisst ihr was richtig, Moment, welche Maus ist denn jetzt die richtige?
Die hier, das ist die richtige Maus hier.
Also, ähm, wer noch nicht gesehen hat, was ich mir da an Rechner zusammengebaut hab,
kann einfach auf meinen YouTube-Channel gucken, das letzte Video, da stehen die Details drin, was das ist.
Und, ähm, lasst die Musik ein bisschen leiser, ok, mach ich.
So, aha, ich denke, so müsste es jetzt ganz gut sein.
So, ähm, wo war ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Tja, das hab ich ganz vergessen, zumindest, was da drinne ist, ich sag's nochmal ganz kurz,
ähm, das ist ein, sieht man doch hier auch irgendwo, oder, genau, das ist ein neuer Coffee Lake,
neue Coffee Lake CPU von Intel, ein i7-8700K, ähm, mit einem SROG Mainboard,
und zwar hier mit dem da, SROG Fertility Z370 Professional Gaming 1.7.
So, und wir werden jetzt mal gucken, wie weit sich das Ding übertakten lässt.
Ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal ein bisschen das BIOS, dann laden wir uns erstmal die notwendigen Tools dazu runter, die man braucht.
Ich hab hier im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen rumgespielt, und, wisst ihr, was ich richtig cool finde?
Dass das, dass das hier das Eats OC ist, das ist so, besonders easy ist das.
Aber das machen wir nicht da drüben, wir machen das über den Advanced Mode.
Was ich übrigens dann ziemlich cool finde an diesem BIOS ist, man hat Maus-Support.
Ok, das ist jetzt nichts Neues, aber ich find's cool.
Und was auch cool ist, äh, das sieht nicht so aus, als wär das so gewollt.
Seht ihr das? Das ist doch nicht so gewollt, wenn ich da mit der Maus reinfahre und es dann komische Farben gibt.
Naja, man kann hier auch drüber BIOS aktualisieren, beziehungsweise UEFI aktualisieren.
Über, direkt hier aus dem UEFI raus, der holt sich da eine IP bei DACP,
connectet sich zu SROC und lädt sich Dinger runter.
Das find ich eigentlich ganz gut.
So, ähm, eben hat jemand noch gefragt.
Jemand hat jemand noch gefragt, warum ich den Netz auf einmal übertakken will.
Wollte ich gesagt haben, ich will das vorher nicht.
Naja, mal ausprobieren halt, ne.
Einfach mal ausprobieren, einfach mal gucken, was geht.
Und 4,3 Gigabyte sollten locker auf allen Kurs möglich sein, ja, das stimmt.
Das ist die Falltakt, für den das nicht weiß.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal ganz kurz das BIOS, was man hier machen kann.
Das ist natürlich auf super fancy gemacht und alles hier, ne.
Es gibt den Eats Mode, das ist der Eats Mode.
Und es gibt den Advanced Mode, der ist natürlich rot, weil advanced, ne.
SROC ist der Meinung, das muss so sein.
Äh, hallo Felix.
So, und da sieht man dann so Dinger wie, was es ist,
wie schnell der Prozessor ist, dass ich 16 Gigabyte RAM drinne hab.
Und dann kann man hier noch zig Dinger einstellen, also quasi,
ob die CPU Strom sparen soll, Virtualisierungsfunktion und so geduldens.
Aber das muss uns jetzt eigentlich alles gar nicht großartig interessieren.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das meiste, was hier drin steht,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was ein DMI ASPM Support ist.
Und die Description ist auch nicht sonderlich hilfreich.
Ist auch egal, brauch man nicht.
Der Netzwerk hat ein 10G-Interface, deswegen hab ich mir das Mainboard gekauft.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Äh, ja, es gibt auch einen WLAN-Onboard bzw. Plutus.
Ich hab es hauptsächlich wegen Plutus gekauft.
Man kann irgendwelche LEDs anschalten, das ist wurscht.
Hier sieht man, wie schnell der Lüfter ist.
Zeug. So, und Raid verwenden wir übrigens nicht hier.
Das ganze Fake-Raid-Zeugs, da braucht kein Mensch.
So, was uns hauptsächlich interessieren wird heute, ist dieses Menü hier,
was man hier so einstellen kann.
Und das BIOS hat standardmäßig so ein paar Presets zu übertakten.
Aber die werden wir nicht verwenden, weil die sind in der Regel scheiße.
Ich bin also auch nicht so der große Übertaktungsprofi, muss ich sagen.
Hast du dir mal überlegt, deine CPU zu köpfen?
Überlegt schon, machen werde ich es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder mal gucken, mal gucken, wie warm sie wird.
Mal gucken, wie warm sie wird.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich das mache.
Ich werde einfach gucken, was das Höchste ist, was ich hinkriege,
ohne dass die Temperaturen total aus dem Ruder laufen.
Sebaru wurde meine Donation von gestern angezeigt.
Das Problem ist, ich habe jetzt meinen zweiten Rechner nicht,
wo ich immer während dem Stream Sachen nachgucke.
Vielleicht ich kann jetzt gar nicht, aber ich muss mal gucken.
Vielleicht kann ich das doch irgendwie nachgucken.
Nee, geht nicht.
Geht ja logischerweise.
Ich habe jetzt die Tastatur am anderen Rechner dran,
dass ich hier was machen kann.
Ich gucke nachher mal, okay?
Geht gerade nicht.
So, jetzt laden wir, jetzt gehen wir erstmal ins Windows rein
und laden uns mal die nötigen...
Ja, wir können safen und exiten.
Ich habe hier eh nichts geändert.
No Signal.
Auch gut.
Jetzt habt ihr es ja mal so kurz im Hintergrund gehört,
passt das ungefähr, wenn ich was sage,
zu dem, was ich drücke und tippe?
Also ich habe mir jetzt den Delay eingestellt,
von einer Sekunde auf mein Mikrofon.
Das müsste auch ungefähr hinkommen,
so zu dem, was die Elgato Capture Card für einen Delay drin hat.
So.
So, was brauchen wir?
Das wichtigste, was man braucht, ist erstmal Prime95,
um zu testen, ob die CPU auch ordentlich läuft,
nachdem man es übertaktet hat.
Das kenne ich noch von früher, das ist das wichtigste.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so Stand der Technik ist,
dass man das heute immer noch mit Prime95 macht,
aber ich werde das mit Prime95 machen.
Guck mal, kam sogar als letztes mit einer neuen Version raus.
Geiler Scheiß, ja?
Wie viel hat dich der Rechner so gekostet?
Also wenn man nur die Teile nimmt, die ich neu gekauft habe,
ich weiß, gucken wir doch mal.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Max FPS Real Life, ja?
Gucken wir doch mal,
ich habe doch einen Link unter meinem letzten YouTube-Video gehabt,
wo ich das...
Da.
Da sieht man noch, was der ganze Krampel gekostet hat.
Also er würde bei den billigsten Anbietern
wohl 2300 Euro kosten, der PC,
aber die Grafikkarte hatte ich ja schon wieder.
Also kannst du nochmal 900 Euro einfach abziehen.
Scheiß teuer.
Na gut, die kauft sich ja so, in der Form jetzt auch keiner mehr.
Die habe ich ja damals von Nvidia bekommen, als es ganz neu war.
Deswegen ist es auch die Founders Edition,
haben manche Leute gefragt.
Warum Founders Edition?
Also, sagen wir mal, so,
was hat es denn gekostet?
1300, in dem Dreh, würde ich sagen.
Ja, und der Noctua-Lüfter ist auf dem Ganzen obendrauf.
Und wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal an,
wie warm das Ganze wird,
so mit Default-Takt, würde ich sagen.
Also mit Default-Takt, Default-Spannung und allem.
Was nimmt man da aktuell so?
Vielleicht kennt sich da einer gut mit aus.
Was nimmt man da aktuell so zum Schauen von...
Gab es da früher?
Zum Schauen von Temperaturen.
Temperaturen und Takt und sowas.
Takt und sowas kann man ja mittlerweile relativ einfach nachgucken.
Das sieht man ja mittlerweile alles hier im Windows-Task-Manager.
Der ist schon deutlich besser als früher.
Also sprich, man sieht hier, das Ding läuft hier gerade runtergedaktet,
weil es nichts machen muss.
So, laden wir uns erstmal Prime auf den Ordner.
Prime.
Packen wir den ganzen Scheiß da rein.
Da merkt man, dass ich Linux-User bin.
So, nebenbei auch noch auf der Arbeit unter anderem.
Ich track und drope nicht.
Ich copy-paste mit Tastatur.
HW-Monitor Sebau.
Ja, genau, das ist das Ding, was ich meinte.
Das ist das hier, das da, ne?
Genau.
Mein Stream hängt.
Warum hängt mein Stream?
Hängt er bei euch auch?
In meiner Vorschau hängt das Stream gerade.
Nee, hängt nicht.
Okay.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also bei mir buffert es wie verrückt.
Aber solange es bei euch nicht hängt, ist gut.
Okay, dann.
Laden wir den Scheiß mal runter.
Ich lad mir solche Tools normalerweise auch ganz gern
bei einer Quelle runter, der ich vertraue.
Normalerweise kann man sagen,
die Seite vom Hersteller ist natürlich immer eine gute Anlaufquelle.
Aber zu diesen ganzen kleinen Klitschen,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das in dem Fall hier bei denen zutrifft,
die bundeln in ihren Downloads öfters mal irgendeine Scheiße,
mit die man sich dann installiert.
Jetzt nix Schlimmes, aber Sachen, die man nicht haben will.
Deswegen lad ich mir das jetzt einfach mal von Heise runter.
Da weiß ich, dass da auf jeden Fall kein Blödsinn drinne ist.
So.
Kannst du jetzt mit dem auf 1080p60 FPS streamen?
Das kann ich mit dem alten auch schon, X-Floor.
Das Problem dabei ist, dass ich plus 6 MBit Upload habe,
als nicht Twitch-Partner.
1080p mit 60 FPS und 6 MBit Bitrate für ein Video,
vor allem, wenn es bewegte Bilder sind, sieht halt scheiße aus.
Prime 26.6.
Okay, und warum ausgerechnet 26.6, Nilsson?
Warum nicht das Neueste?
Ja, auf jetzt, lad runter.
Hopp, warum ist das so lahm?
Heise ist wieder wahnsinnig schnell, wie es aussieht gerade.
Unsere Partner für schnelle und sichere Downloads.
Oh Gott, ist das langsam.
Laden wir es von Chip.
Warum ist das, ey, das ist gerade übertrieben langsam.
Aber andere Seiten, so Google und so, ist schnell,
oder hier so GMX, so eine Mailseite, ist auch lahm.
Ist echt nicht schnell gerade.
Na ja, wir brauchen auch nicht wirklich schnell Internet gerade,
wenn wir recht schnell übertacken.
Auflad runter.
Go, go.
Erbungen zu gekleisterten Seiten immer.
Jetzt lädt er das fünfmal runter, ey.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ich will auch, ich will das doch als ZIP haben, ich will das,
dass die es einem immer so kompliziert machen.
So, wir laden das jetzt von der Herstellerseite runter,
ist mir egal.
ZIP Englisch, gut, easy, download, zack.
HW Monitor, den brauchen wir auf jeden Fall,
dass wir sehen, wie warm der ganze Scheiß wird.
So, das war's, mehr brauchen wir nicht.
Jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal an, wie warm wird der ganze Krempel
jetzt, ohne übertackt zu sein.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Übrigens, ich find's super, dass mir 105 Leute zugucken,
106 Leute zugucken, beim Rechner übertacken.
Okay, übrigens Follows und sowas, falls ich welche kriege,
ich seh's heut alles nicht richtig, weil ich meinen 2. Rechner nicht hab.
Weil ich an dem Monitor meinen neuen Rechner hab.
Und, ne, deswegen seh ich ein bisschen wenig,
was so im Stream heute passiert.
Außer den Chat, den hab ich mir aufgemacht.
Hey Max, wollte dich fragen, wo du dein Stromkabel angeschlossen hast.
Hä, der Steckdose? Wo sonst?
Halbkonnig übertackte mein Rechner.
FunkyDough, wann kommt mal dein Video zu deinem Haus zum Garten?
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Nachdem ich eben massig De-Abo's bekomme aktuell auf YouTube,
einmal, weil ich so lange nichts gemacht hab
und weil YouTube wieder inaktive Konten aufräumt,
vor allem jedes Mal bei einem Upload immer gleich mal 70 De-Abo's oder so,
weiß auch nicht, entweder finden's die Leute einfach nur auf Scheiße,
was ich mache, dann könnt ich einfach nur noch Livestreamen
und mach ich überhaupt keine Videos mehr.
Oder der YouTube-Algorithmus muss ich einfach mal wieder sortieren.
Kann man bei Twitch schon H265 streamen? Weiß ich nicht.
Wenn das geht, wäre das ne Option.
Ach so, jetzt hab ich's gelesen.
Jetzt hab ich's gelesen.
Okay, legen wir mal los.
Also aktuell...
Windows.
Windows!
Ich will das nicht vollbild haben.
Okay, aktuell ist das Ding relativ, relativ cool.
1,23, 22 Grad.
Also wenn man gar nichts drauf macht und gar nichts drauf läuft,
also ne, jetzt läuft ja immerhin noch dieses komische Programm
und das hier, wenn da wirklich gar nichts drauf läuft,
hab ich vorhin schon mal geguckt, dann hat das Eidl 20, 21 Grad.
Die CPU.
Also die ist ziemlich kühl.
Was auch dafür spricht dann, dass halt Lüfter und Wärmel halt passen
und so alles ganz gut sitzt und funktioniert, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Iron Junkie, na das, mit Kreisen macht man nicht mehr.
Ich hab letztens mal geguckt, wie man das so macht
und ich glaub, man macht jetzt Pfeile.
Also nicht mal Kreise und Pfeile, sondern nur noch Pfeile.
Ich glaub, das ist der neueste Trend.
Doch, doch, ich hab das neueste Windows drauf.
Ich hab zumindest mir einen Fall Creators Update ISO gemacht.
Das sollte eigentlich das neueste sein.
Stimmt, das ist auf jeden Fall das neueste Windows.
Ach, wisst ihr was sein kann?
Das ist nicht aktiviert.
Vielleicht zeigt es das nicht an, weil es nicht aktiviert ist.
Das ist aber das neueste Windows.
Ich hab's noch nicht aktiviert.
Vielleicht steht das deswegen nicht drin.
Aber ist ja auch wurscht.
Fangen wir mal an.
Also, das Ding ist idol relativ kühl.
Das scheint alles gut zu sitzen.
Funktionieren 23 Grad.
Hätte ich mich früher immer gefreut, wenn meine CPU nur 23 Grad idol warm gewesen wäre.
Das ist ja auch ein riesen Lüfter.
Ich zeig euch das Teil mal.
Noctua 15S.
Wie heißt das Ding? DH oder so.
NHD15S.
Ein Lüfter zeigen, der da oben drauf ist.
Das ist wirklich ein mega Ding.
Was ist dein Übertaktungsziel?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich will einfach mal gucken, was so geht, ohne dass ich jetzt massiv da Spannung draufhauen will.
Ja, also zwei Volten oder so machen wir dann bestimmt nicht.
Aber davon, das brennt er uns ja halb ab.
So, haben die Bilder von dem Lüfter hier irgendwo?
Ich muss euch das Ding nämlich, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, echt mal zeigen.
Das ist ein wahnsinniges Teil.
Guckt mal, hier sieht man es.
Ungefähr genauso sieht es auf meinem Mainboard auch aus.
Genauso.
So sieht das aus.
Der Lüfter, ich hab's noch nicht im Gehäuse eingebaut.
Das steht hier neben mir auf einem Karton, das Ding.
Also quasi nur Mainboard mit Netzteil daneben unter dem Lüfter drauf.
Ich sehe eigentlich erst mal die Hälfte von dem, was ich gerade hier, wenn ich um die Ecke gucke, sehe, ist Lüfter.
Das ist halt ein richtig krasses Ding, oder? Guckt es euch mal an.
So, okay.
Also, wir wollten jetzt mal gucken, was das Ding für Temperaturen hat, ohne dass wir was übertaktet haben.
Sieht ihr, das eidelt rum, macht nichts.
Hat sich ganz runtergetaktet schon.
Ab und zu taktet es sich mal hoch.
Es ist ja so, dass bei Intel gibt es ja diese Geschichte mit, wir schalten uns hoch, wenn wir noch quasi, wie nennen sie das?
Also Platz haben, was Temperaturen angeht.
Nilsson, wie heißt das richtig? Du weißt das bestimmt.
Also sprich, wenn noch Luft nach oben ist, dass die CPU eben noch Dings Limit, Temperatur Limit oder so, noch nicht ausgereizt hat,
dann können sich auch einzelne Kerne hochtakken, oder auch die gesamte CPU hochtakken, je nachdem, wie viele Kerne ausgelastet sind.
Ist ein Kern ausgelastet, dann kann er sich bis zu 4,7 Gigahertz hochtakken.
Sind alle Kerne ausgelastet, dann maximal bis 4,3.
Das ist die Fault, das funktioniert, deswegen hat eben vorhin einer so auch Spaß geschrieben, 4,3 alle Kerne werden gehen.
4,3 alle Kerne müssen gehen, weil das ist die Fault.
Und, nee Nilsson, ich meine nicht Turbo Boost, ich meine, wie dieses Limit heißt, so was.
Thermal Limit oder irgendwie so was.
Naja, zumindest je nachdem, wie viele Kerne ausgelastet sind, umso weniger hochtakken die Dinger sich.
Also das heißt, ein Kern bis zu 4,7 Gigahertz ist schon die Fault.
So, dann schmeißen wir doch mal Prime an.
Just Stress Testing.
Und hauen mal drauf, wir machen jetzt einfach mal volle Pulle Leistung.
Man sieht nichts, aber das Ding rechnet.
Und man sieht hier auch, Temperatur geht klar instant mal 73 Grad drauf.
Und man sieht es hier, maximale Takt, 4,3 auf allen Kern.
Also es ist der maximale Takt, der geht.
Danke für den Follow, ich habe eben Follower Sound gehört.
Thermal Limit, ja das kann sein.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das wird ziemlich warm das Ding.
Aber das Zeug wird halt warm.
Also da kann ich jetzt auch nichts machen.
Das Ding hat den besten Lüfter oder einen den besten Lüftern, die es zur Zeit gibt.
Das ist ordentlich angezogen, da ist ordentliche Klecks Wärmerleitpaste drauf.
Ich habe das genauso gemacht, wie das Noctua im Handbuch geschrieben hat.
Also sprich, man soll so einen halben Zentimeter dicken, oder ne 5 Millimeter dicken haben sie geschrieben,
Tropfen drauf machen auf die CPU und dann halt den Lüfter anziehen.
So, wie man das macht.
Und dann verteilt sich das hier ordentlich, wenn man anzieht.
Kleinen Rotti, das ist alles noch Default.
Der zieht hier oben, zieht da gerade 1,46.
Also man kann ja, also dieses VID, das habe ich nachgeguckt, das ist was die CPU haben möchte.
Und man kann jetzt noch einstellen, dann im BIOS später entweder den absoluten Wert oder dann Offset,
quasi was da noch dazu oder was da noch mehr dazu kommt oder halt eben weniger.
Also könnte ein Offset quasi einstellen von 0,01, dann würde er halt immer mehr geben
oder halt minus 0,01, dann würde er immer weniger geben, als die CPU haben möchte.
Köpfst du die CPU, weiß ich noch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich gucke mal, was geht mit dem, die Vorzeugs, was ich habe.
Weil ich meine, ich habe jetzt einen, ich hatte mega Glück, dass ich einen 8700K gekriegt habe.
Ich habe aber drei Shops vorbestellt.
Und ich will den jetzt nicht kaputt machen.
Metallkühlpaste hilft.
Also cheat, ich habe die Paste genommen von Noctua, die dabei ist.
Und ich denke mal, die wird ganz okay sein.
Musik, Halbkorn, das kann ich dir posten, das ist ein Radio auf YouTube.
So, such einfach mal Chillstep Mixhound Radio, dann findest du es.
So, also man sieht, das wird ordentlich warm.
Aber man muss sagen, das ist ja mit dem aktuellen Prime, das ist die maximalste Leistung, die irgendwie geht.
Komplett ausgelastet ist das Teil gerade, bis unter das Dach.
Das läuft auf dem höchsten Takt, der geht, wenn alles ausgelastet ist.
Plus, das ist extrem optimiert und benutzt auch die neuen Befehle, die quasi noch nicht lange gibt bei CPUs.
Das heißt, Prime verursacht wirklich Hitze ohne Ende.
Beim Spielen wird das nicht ganz so warm werden.
Da können wir schon mal von ausgehen.
Und ich glaube, maximal darf das Ganze 105 Grad warm werden, wenn ich das jetzt richtig im Kopf habe, weil ich vorhin geguckt habe.
Aber da werden wir auf gar keinen Fall hingehen.
Also sag mal so, maximal, würde ich mal sagen, keine Ahnung, 95.
Ich weiß nicht, bis wie viel wir es ausprobieren.
Was zockst du heute?
Wir zocken heute BIOS-Settings, Optik-Daddy.
Mach mal die Musik leiser und mach mal die Musik lauter.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ich mach's mal ein bisschen leiser.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt Prime ein bisschen laufen lassen.
Also sag mal so 79, 79, 80 Grad wird das Ganze warm.
Die Belüftungssituation könnte vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser sein im Gehäuse später, weil aktuell steht es halt einfach nur da.
Dafür ist es halt offen, da musst du nicht viel belüften.
Aber im Gehäuse hast du dann halt noch vorne Lüfter, hinten Lüfter, da hast du noch so einen schönen Luftfluss um das Ganze.
Also vielleicht ist es im Gehäuse dann nochmal ein ganz kleines Ticken Kühler, aber ich glaube, das wird sich nicht so viel nehmen.
Okay, also wir wissen jetzt, das Ding funktioniert, das Ding bleibt im Rahmen, mehr darf es nicht, aber damit kann man leben.
Ich hab den Noctua Lüfter drauf gerade, Box gibt es übrigens nicht für die CPU.
Was, es geht um die Stimme und nicht um die Musik?
Bin ich zu leise?
Ich kann mich lauter drehen, aber sobald ich dann halt mal ein bisschen was Lauteres sag, dann übersteuert es gleich.
Also, so wie ich mir das ja angucke, ist das von der Abmischung her eigentlich okay.
Zu laut jetzt, Leute, ich hab überhaupt nichts umgestellt.
Das einzige, was ich gemacht hab, ist das Mikrofon ein bisschen näher am Mund.
War super, okay, also weiter geht's.
Gut, also, passt alles, gut, wunderbar, stopp, und man sieht hier, kaum gestoppt, geht's wieder runter.
Stream tust du noch von einer alten Mühle aus, richtig.
Ich hab dann das Capture Card eingestöpselt und den neuen hier in die Capture Card gesteckt.
Übrigensweise halt den Monitor am Display-Port und die Capture Card am HDMI-Ausgang.
Mittlerweile hat ja glücklicherweise die Mainboards mehrere Ausgänge, praktisch.
Gut, dann gehen wir mal ins Bios und übertakt eine Runde.
Jetzt muss ich mir erstmal die Settings noch mal in Ruhe angucken.
Was ist dein Ziel bei OC? Ich hab kein Ziel, ich gucke einfach mal, was geht.
Willst du noch das RAM overclocken? Nee, das bringt nicht ganz sonderlich viel.
So, jetzt sind wir erstmal wieder im Eats Mode.
Wollen wir mal, wollen wir mal so aus Spaß an der Freude, in der Hoffnung der Rechner kackt da nicht ab,
wollen wir mal so aus Spaß an der Freude gucken, wie gut die SROG Profile sind, die dabei sind.
Wollen wir mal das SROG Turbo 5 GHz Profil ausprobieren?
Wollen wir das einfach mal testen? Ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert, ne?
Ja, kann ich, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es gut funktioniert.
Was, wie erst 4,7? Das ist ja langweilig.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn wir es ausprobieren, machen wir wenn schon mal 5,
weil da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass es eh nicht funktionieren wird.
Was hat er jetzt eingestellt? Ja gut, 50, 1,5 drauf.
Mal gucken, ob das Ding überhaupt startet jetzt.
Schauen wir mal, dass da irgendwas kaputt geht, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Angst,
das Zeug wird sich schon alles ordnungsgemäß abschalten.
Okay, Windows startet schon mal, das ist erstmal nicht verkehrt.
Wisst ihr was, wir ziehen uns den Krempel mal auf den Desktop.
Okay, es läuft hier, habt ihr gesehen, mit 5, also sobald ein bisschen was ist, läuft er mit 5 GHz.
So und jetzt gucken wir mal, was passiert, sobald ich da auch ein bisschen Last drauf gebe.
Klein roti, aber Prime benutzt AVX und OBS auch habe ich gelesen.
Zeig mal V-Kurs, was soll ich zeigen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie mein Windows-Taskmanager irgendwelche Dinge einstellt.
Nimm 27.9 von Prime.
Kennst du die perfekten Settings für Prime? Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Ich würde nämlich einfach sagen, ich mache jetzt das hier und drücke auf OK.
Das wurde vorher schon warm genug.
Ach so, in Hardware-Monitor V-Kur, okay.
Also quasi sowas, sowas in der Richtung von 1,54.
1,5 hat er jetzt, also das, was wir eingestellt haben.
Egal, bam.
Was?
Ach so, ja, du hast es ja gerade schon gezeigt, ich bin mit dem Chat hinten dran.
Okay, bam.
Das wird schon mal sehr warm.
Ähm, die CPU hat sich gerade runtergedankt auf 4,3.
Warum?
Ja, die hat sich abgeschaltet.
Gut, das war zu viel, mehr geht nicht.
Mehr geht nicht, das funktioniert nicht.
Zumindest nicht mit der Standardkühlung drauf.
Das klappt nicht.
Keine Chance.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Okay, da müssen wir, da müssen wir ein bisschen konservativer rangehen an die Sache.
Ey, ich meine, man kann es ja mal probieren.
Und irgendwie Bock da jetzt rumzubasteln dran, habe ich auch nicht.
Der ohne Kohle, eventuell mit weniger Spannung, ja kann sein.
Probieren wir erst mal, wir tasten uns erst mal ran.
Also das war jetzt ja gerade nur just for fun.
Habe ich nicht mit gerechnet, dass das funktioniert.
So, machen wir das mal aus und stellen mal von Hand was ein.
Hat er auch dieser Things hier wieder zurückgemacht?
Ja, passt, sehr schön.
CPU Köpfen plus flüssig Metall.
Wie macht man das eigentlich mit Köpfen?
Ich habe mir das vor Jahren mal angeschaut, so einen, ich glaube bei,
ich glaube bei Computer Base, so einen Guide, habe ich mir da mal durchgelesen.
Wie macht man das aktuell?
Was entfernt man dabei eigentlich genau?
Da gibt es ein Tool von der Bauer.
Also ich gehe mal davon ein, man entspannt.
Also man macht oben wahrscheinlich von der CPU den, also so stelle ich mir das vor,
man macht oben von der CPU den Deckel ab.
Oder wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Dann machst du die alte Paste runter und flüssig Metall drauf.
Ha.
Ja gut, das kann man schon machen.
Wie groß ist die Gefahr dabei, dass die CPU kaputt geht?
Wie groß ist die Chance, dass die CPU dabei kaputt geht?
Weil ich meine, ich werde kein 8700 kriegen in nächster Zeit mehr.
Okay, jetzt, das mache ich dann vielleicht nochmal.
Aber jetzt, jetzt mache ich es bestimmt nicht.
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal was noch sonst, was so geht.
Multi-Core Enhancement.
Wofür ist denn das da?
Perform the highest frequency on all CPU Cores at the same time.
Warum sollte man das wollen?
Weil ich meine, wenn der CPU Core nichts zu tun hat,
warum sollte der dann bei der höchsten Frequenz laufen?
Wo ist das Sinn von diesem Setting?
Man weiß es nicht.
Oder vielleicht verstehe ich das Setting auch bloß falsch.
Gut, also gucken wir mal, was wir einschalten können.
All Cores kann man einschalten.
Ah, dann verschwindet dieses Setting da oben auch, verstehe, okay.
Also was kann man alles einstellen?
All Cores kann man einstellen per Core.
Hä? Moment.
Specific per Core.
Okay, Moment, wo ist das?
Was ist da jetzt der Unterschied?
Also das hier verstehe ich.
Hier kann ich einen Multiplikator einstellen.
Also sagen wir jetzt mal hier irgendwie 47.
Dann zeigt der ja auch hier oben schon an.
Dann laufen einfach quasi alle Kerne jetzt mit maximal 4,7 Gigahertz.
Anstatt früher quasi mit 4,3 maximal.
So würde ich das jetzt verstehen.
Aber die große Preisfrage ist,
was ist der Unterschied zwischen diesem Setting per Core und Specific per Core?
Die Anzeige rechts von der Description kann man ja schon mal voll vergessen.
Also per Core würde ich so verstehen,
dass man hier eben das Limit einstellen kann,
wie hoch der Multiplikator ist bei wie viel Kerne gerade benutzt werden.
Das ist ja das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Wo wird ein Kern benutzt, kann er bis 4,7 Gigahertz hochtacken,
halt diesen Kern.
Werden zwei Kerne benutzt bis 4,8 und so weiter.
Bis halt eben bei allen Kern, wie wir eben am Anfang auch gesehen haben,
maximal 4,3.
Das heißt das, was da steht, sind die default Settings.
Die große Frage ist jetzt,
was ist das hier Specific per Core?
Max Ratio, Limit Ratio. Ist Max und Limit nicht so oftmals gleich bedeutend?
xlappentv, Max ist einfach der real money boy.
Macht sich bei sowas nicht um wasted 400 Euro Sorgen,
sondern darum, dass er keinen Ersatz bekommt.
Ich mache mir um beide Sorgen.
Tatsächlich um die 400 Euro weniger, aber dass ich keinen Ersatz bekomme.
Ich muss mal mein G2A Pay mal überweisen, so langsam.
Das habe ich noch so viel Kohle drauf liegen,
wer weiß, falls es die irgendwann nicht mehr gibt.
Hat jemand, also jetzt mal ernsthaft, hat jemand eine Idee?
Ich glaube mein Chat ist abgekackt.
Also Moment, Moment Leute, ich muss mein Chat refreshen.
Okay, hat jemand eine Ahnung,
was der Unterschied ist zwischen per Core und Specific per Core?
Weil ich mein, per Core habe ich jetzt gerade gesagt,
das wird so sein, wie ich das gerade erklärt habe.
Hier kann ich quasi einstellen,
wenn wie viele Cores ausgelassen sind, wie hoch der Multiplikator ist.
Das ist ja nice.
Aber was ist Specific per Core?
Weil hier kann ich, wie viel kann ich denn hier eintippen?
255 Watt?
Was?
Hoffe mal bitte über dem Kern, wenn du Specific ausgewählt hast,
dann steht da ja wieder ein Text.
Wo steht da ein Text?
Also, also ich check den Unterschied nicht
zwischen dem Setting und dem Setting.
Übrigens, das mit dem QR-Code, das habe ich vorhin mal ausprobiert.
Man kommt bei jedem QR-Code, egal wo man hingeht,
kommt man einfach auf dem PDF für das Mainboard raus, vom Handbuch.
Okay, also ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
was der Unterschied ist, Specific per Core und per Core.
Das müssen wir gleich mal nachgucken,
wenn wir wieder im Windows drin sind.
Gucken wir uns mal das Handbuch aus.
Ja genau, und was soll 255 Ratio sein, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Ach so, der Evil Cookie, das kann natürlich sein.
Hier kann man Specific per Core, hier kann man wahrscheinlich nicht einstellen,
also hier kann man einstellen, wenn ein Core benutzt wird,
wenn zwei Cores benutzt werden, hier kann man wahrscheinlich wirklich einstellen,
der erste Kern soll so und so viel haben,
der zweite Kern soll so und so viel haben und so weiter.
Also sprich, wenn nicht alle Kerne gleich viel oder gleich gut,
in Anführungsstrichen, sich übertakten lassen, dann könnte man das,
ja da Patrick schreibt es gerade, dann könnte man das hier wahrscheinlich einstellen.
Oh das ist cool, das ist nice, das ist wirklich viele Optionen, die es hier gibt.
Aber das erste, was wir jetzt mal probieren ist, wir machen, wir stellen mal ein per,
wir stellen mal ein, ich überlege gerade was ich machen soll,
ob ich all Cores einstellen soll, mal quasi 47.
Ich meine Simon, wir fangen mal mit 47 an, weil 47 ist der maximale Turbotakt,
die fallmäßig, wenn nur ein Kern belastet ist.
Das heißt, dass das Ding 47 packt, wenn man vielleicht ein bisschen die Spannung anhebt oder so,
kann man von ausgehen.
Oder aber wir sagen quasi per Core und tragen hier überall 47 ein,
was aber auch ziemlich bescheuert war, das kommt ja aufs gleiche raus.
Wir machen mal all Core 47, fangen wir mal damit an, 47 sollte eigentlich ganz gut gehen hoffe ich.
Ich sehe leider den Namen gerade nicht.
Medicaid, was ist denn hier der Standard V-Core von dem Ding?
47 und nur, was kann man hier sonst noch?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die ganzen Settings hier alles sind.
Das ist der Bus, den will ich nicht übertakten.
Per Bus könnte man quasi CPUs übertakten, die sich nicht von Haus aus per Multiplikator übertakten lassen,
aber das brauchen wir nicht, weil ich habe ja eine Card-CPU, das heißt, die lässt sich auch ordentlich übertakten.
Sollte man das hier noch fest einstellen?
Ich glaube, das hier sollte man noch fest einstellen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht verkehrt, wenn man das hier nochmal auf 44 stellt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Wenn ich das hier auf Auto stelle und das hier auf Auto stelle... Ach so, nee, Moment.
Ah nee, Standard ist 3,7, ah, vergesse.
All Core, also All Core 47, wir lassen das Auto.
Lass es einfach mal Auto stehen, gut ist.
Der Cache läuft mit einem anderen Takt, oder was?
Naja, was auch immer.
Lassen wir das erstmal so stehen. 47 auf allen Kernen.
Da steht auch Should be the same as CPU Ratio, also machen wir mal so.
Das könnte vielleicht ein bisschen viel sein.
Wir probieren es einfach mal aus. 44 oder 45 erstmal.
Ich würde sagen, wir können es doch einfach mal auf Auto lassen, oder?
Wir lassen es einfach mal auf Auto.
Welchen Prozessor habe ich? 8700K.
Wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal auf Auto stehen.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal ein Setting zu einer Zeit, dass man am Ende noch weiß, was eigentlich ist.
Hier muss man vielleicht auch noch dran rumstellen, habe ich vorhin irgendwo gelesen.
Den Rest lassen wir einfach mal defaultmäßig, so wie es ist.
So, geben wir nochmal ein bisschen mehr Spannung drauf.
Ja, Offset oder Fixed?
Also Offset ist, so wie ich das verstanden habe, dass man halt immer auf das, was die CPU gerade anfragt,
auch eben den Offset oben drauf haut.
Und Fixed ist, der Fixed ist eigentlich Blödsinn.
Also ich meine Fixed, vielleicht jetzt zum Testen am Anfang, könnte man mal sagen.
Aber allgemein würde ich sagen, wenn der Eidl ist und sich runtertaktiziert,
dann kann er natürlich auch, dann kann er ja auch ein bisschen weniger sich nehmen.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Also machen wir mal Offset, fangen wir mal an mit einem Offset von 100.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da im Endeffekt rauskommt.
Passt das eigentlich so ungefähr, wenn ich jetzt hier so quasi sage,
klick, klick, klick, klick.
Also ist das von der Verzögerung her okay, wie ich das eingestellt habe mit einer Sekunde von meinem Mikrofon?
Oder ist das verzögert irgendwie?
Weil das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Über Capture Card habe ich ja Delay beim Aufnehmen.
Und beim Mikrofon direkt am Rechner natürlich kein Delay.
Deswegen habe ich da jetzt eingestellt.
So, probieren wir das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Also sprich, weil das vielleicht ein bisschen viel ist.
Willst du heute noch die CPU grillen?
Na, ich hoffe nicht.
Die schaltet sich eh ab vorher bzw. regelt runter.
Okay, wir geben jetzt einfach mal 100.
Bäm.
Das heißt, wir haben dann anstatt 1,3, 1,4 oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Testen wir mal.
Solange Windows schon mal bootet, kann nicht allzu viel kaputt sein.
Die maximal sichere Spannung ist 1,52.
Das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Das heißt, wenn der sich maximal 1,52 nimmt unter voller Pulle,
dann nimmt er sich jetzt 1,62.
Oder?
Das wäre ganz schön viel.
Gucken wir mal, Hardware-Monitor anmachen.
4,7 auf allen Kernen, okay.
Passt.
Eidelt noch so vor sich hin bei 24 Grad.
Gucken wir mal, probieren wir mal aus.
Bäm.
Man sieht gar nicht mehr alles.
Der fährt aber rein hier.
Hört ihr das, der Lüfter?
Hört man das?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das hört, aber...
790 Grad, Alter.
24 Grad Eidl, weiß ich bei mir.
Wie warm ist das hier drin?
Ich habe gerade kein Thermometer, aber es ist relativ angenehm.
Ich kann sagen, ich habe hier 1,25, 22 Grad oder so.
26, äh, 96, 97.
Ripp.
Aber seht ihr mal hier?
Alles funktioniert.
Kackt nix ab.
Äh, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Ich glaube, wir sind fast schon am Limit.
Was willst du noch viel machen?
Okay, wir probieren jetzt noch mal die alte Prime-Version.
Wir probieren jetzt noch mal die alte Prime-Version,
die einer vorgeschlagen hat, die bleibt ein bisschen kühler,
weil sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht die neuen CPU-Befehle verwendet.
Also das ist jetzt wirklich hardcore.
Wir kriegen mit nichts wahrscheinlich mehr Auslastung hin,
als mit dem aktuellen Prime.
Geht das lange gut mit 890 Grad?
Ja, solange er unter dem Maximum bleibt, geht das gut.
Gesund für den ist das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber ich meine, wer hat schon seine CPU mal kaputt gemacht?
Das haben die wenigsten geschafft.
Okay, was für einen Prime sollte ich nehmen?
27.9 hat einer geschrieben.
27.9.
Was ist das für eine Seite, die kenne ich nicht.
Download, wo gibt es den überhaupt?
Wo gibt es den bei der Prime?
Gibt es den auch auf der offiziellen Seite zum Download?
Haben die alte Version hier?
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Haben die irgendwie eine Seite mit alten Versionen oder so?
Was ist das hier für eine Seite?
Von der Seite lade ich mir nichts runter, die kenne ich nicht.
Im Forum gibt es sie, okay.
Ach, hier.
Also ich sehe hier plus 27, aber das wird es wahrscheinlich auch tun.
Moment, hier ist doch die Url.
Hier haben die wahrscheinlich einfach alle.
Gucken wir mal.
Hier sind wahrscheinlich alle Versionen drauf.
So, super.
Prime 95, 27, 279.
Gott.
Prime, alt.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das damit kühler bleibt.
Der neue Kohl, ja, so ungefähr.
Weil da kommt man vielleicht ein bisschen mehr in die Nähe von dem, was vielleicht Games verursachen oder so.
Aber an sich ist das mit diesem neuesten Prime, der quasi auch die ganzen neuen Befehle verwendet,
die eben richtig hitzigen, der ist schon am besten.
Also man sieht schon, dann eigentlich ist Schluss, ja.
Ich meine, ich hatte am Anfang mal so ein bisschen Bedenken,
vielleicht habe ich zu wenig Wärmeleitpaste drauf gemacht,
aber ich habe es genauso gemacht, wie es drauf steht.
Aber man muss ja auch sagen, das Ding hat Eidl 22 Grad und standardmäßig halt 79, ohne Übertakte.
Das ist okay für Luftkühlung bei dem Ding.
Just stress test, jawoll.
Na, bleibt ein bisschen kühler, habe ich das Gefühl.
Minimal, bleibt ein paar Grad kühler.
Der ohne Kohle so schnell wie die Temperatur hochspringt, ist die Paste möglich, weiß nicht.
Brauch halt, der verursacht halt einfach Hitze.
Ja, das ist wieder wie KleinRotti sagt, wir stellen jetzt die Spannung noch ein bisschen runter.
Ach, die vom Intel, ach so.
Ach, das mein ihr, ja, das ist von Arsch, das ist wirklich von Arsch.
Das Intel, keine Ahnung, ein Micro-Cent spart oder so pro CPU.
Also es nimmt sich eigentlich, nimmt sich nicht großartig hier was, ne, die beiden Prime-Versionen.
Also starten wir mal neu, dann machen wir den V-Core ein bisschen runter.
Da labern auch alle vom Köpfen.
Tja, vielleicht mache ich das auch.
Wir gucken, erinnert mich mal dran, ich gucke mir jetzt gleich mal dieses Köpftool an, was es da angeblich gibt.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Zuschauer, 140 Leute beim sinnlosen Übertacken von meiner neuen CPU.
Oh, ich muss ganz wichtig, ich muss noch einen Titel schreiben, Rechner übertacken, 8700K.
Fuck, ich kann ja gar nicht schreiben jetzt, nein.
Ich habe die Tastatur am anderen Rechner, null.
Ups, da habe ich Schrieb und gedrückt, grandios.
So, wir machen jetzt die Spannung noch ein bisschen runter.
Gehen wir mal vom Eats, kann man das eigentlich umstellen, dass ich nicht mehr standardmäßig im Advanced Setup lande und nicht im Eats Setup?
Ah hier, UEFI Setup Style, Advanced, easy, easy.
Komm mal, sind wir Profis oder nicht?
Also wir wollen eventually im Advanced Modus.
Ok, jetzt schrauben wir da mal ein bisschen runter.
Machen wir mal ein bisschen weg. Machen wir mal ein bisschen weniger.
Machen wir mal 0,7 mehr.
Zumindest wissen wir, dass Prime anscheinend, ich meine, wir müssen es noch ein bisschen länger laufen lassen.
Diese 5 Minuten Prime waren jetzt nicht so aussagekräftig, ja.
Aber zumindest wissen wir, dass mit einem Offset von 100 das Ganze zumindest auf den ersten Blick halbwegs stabil läuft.
Dann haben wir mal 70.
Ich guck mir das mal an dann, wie man das Zeug entfernt von der CPU.
Was braucht man da für alles?
Also gefragt an die Leute, die schon gemacht haben, was ich meine, Wärmerleitpasta hab ich noch genug.
Aber das wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht bringen.
Also mal angenommen, ich mach das dann ab.
Wo gibt es dieses Tool?
Das da? Ist es das da?
Das Ding?
Sieht aus wie ein Minischraubstock.
Das Ding.
Okay.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, wie das funktioniert.
Da ist er. Der Bauer.
Führ mal bitte vor. Blitz.
Moment, Moment, wie geht das?
Okay, man steckt die CPU da rein.
Aktuell ist bei mir die Wärmerleitpasta natürlich hier oben drauf, andersherum geht es ja nicht.
So.
Draubt man das da rein.
Und jetzt drückt man es wahrscheinlich ab damit, wenn man einfach nur feste dagegen.
Genau, so hab ich mir das auch vorgestellt gerade.
Und dann ist ab.
Und dann sollte man da wahrscheinlich besser nicht drauf spucken, husten, fingern.
Ach, das ist die Wärmerleitpasta von Intel hier, oder was?
Boah, das ist ja räudig.
Jetzt realisiere ich ja erstmal, wie...
Ach du Scheiße, ist das kacke.
Ich realisiere jetzt ja gerade mal erstmal, was das Problem ist.
Alter, ist das kacke.
So.
Warum komm ich jetzt eigentlich nicht auf meinen anderen Rechner rüber, was soll das?
Ich muss mir mal mit der Tastatur auf den anderen Rechner rüber.
Moment, Leute, warte mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz auf den Rechner, Maus.
Ah, super, geht jetzt nicht.
Kacke.
Komm ich jetzt, komm ich jetzt nicht mal rüber auf den anderen Rechner, ist auch geil.
Muss ich jetzt, ich muss gleich dann mal schnell die Tastatur umstabseln.
Ähm, okay.
Das heißt, jetzt, ähm, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen weniger Spannung drauf.
Jetzt gucken wir nochmal, wie warm da wieder wird.
Und während hier Prime läuft...
Was ist das eigentlich für kacke Musik, äh, TF.
Geh mal weg.
Jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt die passende Benchmark, muss ich.
Jawoll.
So, ist das gut.
Komm, Benchmark, äh, nicht Benchmark, Kasten.
Passende Overclock Musik.
Da scheint ein bisschen, scheint ein minimal kühler zu bleiben, das Ganze.
Jetzt hat sich die Frage, ob Prime noch durchläuft mit weniger Spannung.
Ich hab' ein bisschen leiser gemacht.
Eiskäuter schreibt, ich programmiere derzeit etwas in C-Sharp.
Wenn du willst, Eiskäuter, kannst du, kannst du das schicken.
Und wir gucken uns das irgendwann mal im Stream an.
Overwatch Event Stream?
Nee, ich hab' schon Overwatch Event Stream gemacht.
Ähm, Leute, ich bin mal zehn Sekunden hier unter dem Schreibtisch
und stöpseln mal die Tastatur um.
Vom einen Rechner an den anderen, dass ich wieder meinen Mouse-Sharing
anmachen kann, was abgekackt ist.
Und, weil wir müssen E-Prime laufen lassen.
Und erst mal in den Time-Test klettern.
Das wird immer noch scheiß warm, ey.
Um nicht zu sagen viel zu warm.
Warum geht mein Mouse-Sharing nicht?
Was ist das denn?
What the fuck?
Das ist ganz schön nervig, wenn mein Mouse-Sharing nicht geht.
Ich hab' nur eine Maus und eine Tastatur dran.
Am wenigsten haben wir die passende Musik.
Zeig mal den V-Core, äh, da, hier.
Plus, plus, äh, äh, 0,7.
Also quasi wahrscheinlich 1,6 oder sowas gerade.
Wir brotzen das Ding immer noch.
Aber es läuft, da können wir noch ein bisschen was runtermachen gleich.
Da können wir gleich noch ein bisschen was runtermachen.
Ähm, ich ändere mal den Titel, weil in den Titel muss unbedingt 8700k rein.
Da stehen die Leute oft.
Ja, KleinRotti, ich weiß, das ist die, also wie ich das verstanden hab', ist ja die, ähm, das da,
ist das da, ist das, was die CPU gerne haben möchte.
Also 1,52.
Also so hab' ich das zumindest verstanden.
Ähm, 1,52 will die CPU haben.
Aber wir haben jetzt einen Offset eingestellt von plus 0,7.
Und der Offset, da müsst ihr dann eigentlich nochmal obendrauf kommen.
Also, es haben wir quasi 1,6. Fast.
Aha.
Naja, wie dem auch sei, was auch immer da jetzt, wie es genau ist, ich kann es euch auch nicht genau erklären.
Ich hab' mich da selbst lange nicht damit beschäftigt.
Oh, die labern ja immer noch rum in dem Stream, äh, ist ja nervig.
In dem Radio-Stream. Ach nee, ich war nicht ganz aktuell. So, besser, so ist besser.
Äh, CPU-Z, CPU-Z, ja, das können wir uns auch gleich nochmal runterladen.
Ich muss die Tastatur wieder umstöpseln.
Es ist wirklich lächerlich, dass mein Maus-Sharing nicht funktioniert, ey.
Warum funktioniert das eigentlich nicht? Hat doch die ganze Zeit funktioniert.
Warte mal. Disconnecten wir mal, connecten wir nochmal.
Connected.
Tja.
Das ist richtig kacke, wenn mein Maus-Sharing nicht funktioniert, weil dann komm ich nicht auf den anderen Rechner richtig rüber.
Ich hab' hier nur eine Tastatur, weil das reicht ja normalerweise auch.
Ah, ha, ha, guck mal wer da ist. Da ist ne Maus.
Also, die Tastatur muss ich trotzdem umstöpseln, weil sonst kann sich mein Bios nichts machen.
Aber es ist minimal kühler. Nicht viel, aber ein bisschen.
So, zwei Grad oder so. Also, brauchen wir noch CPU-Z.
CPUs brauchen wir noch.
Und da gucken wir uns mal an, wie viel Spannung das Ding hat.
Warum, warum kann es mir nicht einfach in ZIP runterladen?
Einfach in ZIP, was ich entpacken kann und gut ist.
Also, man sieht, dass die CPU, das funktioniert. Also, der hat keine Fehler oder so.
Also, das läuft schon.
Also, ich hab' hier noch eine Tastatur.
Und...
Nein, ich will kein ZIP. Gibt's das nicht als ZIP oder so?
Hab' ich doch grad angenehm. ZIP. ZIP.
Sollte vielleicht auch das Richtige anklicken, ne?
Okay, machen wir das hier mal zu und schauen wir mal.
Was wir da haben.
Wo steht denn hier jetzt die...
Wo steht denn hier die Spannung?
Seh' ich's jetzt? Ah, hier!
1,28. Ach, das glaub' ich net.
Das glaub' ich net. Ich glaube nicht, dass die...
Also, das hier kommt der Sache doch schon...
Na gut. Das glaub' ich aber net, dass das wirklich 1,26 bekommt.
Und...
Warum bekommt er aber nur so wenig?
Keine Ahnung. Das...
Also, ich mein, der möchte irgendwie 1,5 haben.
Und wir haben schon das Ganze plus 70 eingestellt.
Aber er kriegt nur das.
Ja, aber das stimmt schon, Leute. 1,28 ist schon realistischer.
Weil bei 1,6, da flippt das... da geht das Ding ja...
Da brennt sich das durch die Decke bis in den Keller.
Aber was ich gut finde, ist...
Das ist zumindest auf den ersten Blick mal halbwegs stabil.
Es wird zwar heiß wie Sau.
Entticken kühler als das letzte Mal bleibt's.
Eigentlich sollten wir ja mehr haben.
Also, wir haben ja ein Offset eingestellt von 0,07.
Das heißt, er sollte ein bisschen mehr kriegen.
Wir stellen das Ganze jetzt mal um.
Wir gehen jetzt noch mal ins BIOS und lassen Spannung macht die Fault.
Das stimmt. Prime ist nicht sonderlich realistisch.
So, ich stopf's noch mal kurz.
Dann tun wir noch einen eigentlichen Rechner, an dem ich was mache.
Man steckt der USB generell falsch rum rein.
USB-Anschlüsse sind generell immer falsch rum.
Das geht gar nicht anders.
Man kann USB-Stecker gar nicht richtig reinstecken.
Beim ersten Versuch.
So.
Ich komm wieder nicht rüber auf den anderen Rechner.
Ich krieg echt Anfälle, dass das Sharing von der Maus nicht funktioniert.
Ah, jetzt geht's, passt, alles gut.
So, starten wir neu und machen noch mal...
Wir machen einfach mal den Offset komplett weg.
Wir machen einfach mal den Offset komplett weg und gucken mal, ob's da noch läuft.
So.
Irgendwie ist jetzt die Musik aus, kann das sein?
Ah, da ist er wieder.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal einfach Auto ein.
Also quasi so, wie sich das Intel gedacht hat.
Gucken wir mal.
Also ich mein mit dem Takt geh ich erst mal gar nicht...
Den Takt kann ich schon mal vergessen.
Also mit dem Takt muss ich gar nicht viel höher gehen.
Weil wenn wir jetzt schon bei quasi 4,7 auf allen Kernen
und nur minimal erhöhte Spannung schon quasi am Limit kratzen, wo nicht viel mehr geht.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, also Medicaid, ich glaube nicht, dass ich irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise auf 5 GHz komme,
wenn ich mit 4,7 schon bei fast 100 Grad bin.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das klappt.
So.
Schauen wir mal, was wir jetzt haben.
Ja gut.
Wir haben ja auch keine Last drauf.
Dann machen wir mal ein bisschen Power.
Rechner hängt.
Ich muss Reset drücken.
Oh nee.
Er kann zumindest immerhin noch...
Erster Blue Screen, Leute.
PogChamp Blue Screen.
Press F, genau.
Paid Respect, Leute.
Mein Netzteil hat sich sogar gerade ausgeschaltet.
Also es klickt dann, wenn es sich ausschaltet.
Es sollte sich hoffentlich gleich wieder einschalten.
Sonst muss ich noch mal vor und Stecker ziehen oder so.
Aber ja, nee, passt schon.
Geht schon wieder an.
Gut, das war nichts.
Ja, Fall werde, die Dinge haben mittlerweile QR Codes,
aber der QR Code ist das Sinnloseste aller Zeiten.
Man kommt nämlich einfach nur auf die S-Frog-Seite mit dem PDF.
Also man kriegt keine Erklärung jetzt etwa zu diesem Setting hier oder so.
Was immer der Unterschied zwischen Stable Mode und OC Mode ist.
Okay, 70 hatten wir, 70 ging.
Ich glaube, wir sind wirklich schon fast mehr oder weniger am Ende, was wir machen können.
Was meinst du, Kleinerotti, mach mal die Spannung Fixed.
Ups, Fixed.
Mach mal 1,3 mal Fixed.
Mach mal 1,3 Fixed.
Und guck mal, was da drinne steht.
Guck mal, das Ding bootet doch nicht mal mit 1,3. Da muss ich es auch nicht auf 1,25 stellen.
Ich glaube kaum, dass der Plus Screen jetzt daran liegt, weil ich zu viel Spannung habe.
Eher weil ich zu wenig habe. Ich muss mal Reset drücken.
Oh, der Reset-Drop geht nicht mal mehr.
Habe resettet.
Also ich habe so mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, nein, rechner du kackst doch wieder ab.
Ich war nicht schnell genug mit drücken.
Ja, so ist das.
So.
Ich muss die Delta-Taste fingern. Ich bin Meister im Delta-Taste-Finger.
Hallo, Test, Test, Test.
Ich habe so, aber Fixed ist wirklich doof, das stimmt schon.
Fixed ist doof, da hat der Nilsson Recht.
Ich will jetzt mal gucken, ob das Ding jetzt wenigstens bootet.
Äh, Mafien kriegt man die schon bestellt. Ich habe die bei drei Shops pre-ordert und bei einem hat es dann funktioniert.
Der startet erstmal gar nicht richtig. Der bootet nicht mal.
Warum bootet er denn nicht?
Also so mit Fixed, V-Core.
Klappt das nicht.
Das sind keine Spannungsfehler-Blootscreens. Also ich wüsste nicht, was das sonst sein soll, um ehrlich zu sein.
Weil ich mein, wetten, wenn ich das jetzt zurückstelle, geht's.
Ich könnte wetten, wenn ich das hier jetzt wieder zurückstelle, quasi auf Offset, auf Offset 70, das was wir eben hatten, dann geht's.
Instant.
Das geht jetzt einfach.
Please wait.
Ja ja, Microsoft Restart. Guck, jetzt funktioniert's. Also es liegt schon an der Spannung, weil das das einzige Setting ist, an dem wir gerade drehen.
Es ist ein Ausschlussverfahren, deswegen, ich hab das nicht wirklich, hatte zwar nicht großartig Plan von, aber wenn man nur an einem Setting dreht und es geht mal und es geht nicht, dann kann es eigentlich nur an dem Setting liegen.
So.
Wie viel haben wir jetzt?
Armour Prime, bisschen Power wieder.
Ich glaube, wir sind wirklich schon so ziemlich am
Maximum.
Was hier so mit mit mit Kühler, wie ich's hab, geht.
Jetzt haben wir hier 1,296.
Ja guck, wir sind hier schon bei bei 91 93 Grad wieder. Also ich würde sagen, mehr geht nicht.
Das einzige, was wir jetzt noch probieren könnten, ist.
Wir können noch mal, genau, der Nilsson schreibt es nämlich gerade. Wir könnten mal den Takt hochstellen auf 4,8.
Wie gesagt, das Teil muss man fast köpfen, dass was geht mit Luftkühlung. Also so von der Theorie her müsste man ja das Teil köpfen, dass überhaupt was geht, egal mit welcher Art von Kühlung.
Weil ich meine, die Hitze muss ja von der Stelle, wo sie entsteht, dorthin, wo sie abtransportiert wird.
Und dann ist es doch eigentlich erstmal egal, ob das dann einen Kupferblock mit Lüfter oben drauf steckt oder eine Wasserkühlung oder sonst was.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass eine Wasserkühlung das Ding auch nicht so viel kühler macht.
Wenn da wirklich diese lächerliche Kacke da mit dieser Wärmeleitpaste innen drin am Start ist.
Weil am Lüfter, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der Lüfter quasi am Limit wäre irgendwie.
Der Lüfter könnte das bestimmt alles ganz gut wegblasen, wenn es halt hinkommen würde.
Okay, also was wir jetzt noch ausprobieren können, wir machen mal 8.
Wir machen mal den Takt noch einen Ticken höher, wir lassen aber die Spannung mal gleich.
Naja, weil es ja bei solchen Tests darum geht, ob es stabil läuft.
Und wenn es unter extremen Bedingungen stabil läuft, kann man davon ausgehen, dass es unter normalen Bedingungen auf jeden Fall auch stabil läuft.
So ähnlich wie es der Patrick gerade geschrieben hat, also The Game 402 meine ich das.
Also wenn es damit geht, geht halt alles andere auch.
Gut, gucken wir mal. Jetzt haben wir 4,8 Gigahertz. So und jetzt machen wir nochmal ein Prime auf.
Und bam.
Ah, na Prime ist abgekackt, glaube ich. Guck mal, der eine Core macht nichts.
Oder? Nee, Prime ist nicht abgekackt.
Das sieht so aus. Läuft noch alles.
So man sieht, wir haben jetzt einen höheren Takt und die Temperatur ändert sich fast gar nicht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht geht ja noch ein bisschen, vielleicht geht ja noch ein bisschen Takt.
Schauen wir mal. Prinks, danke für die ganzen Follows, ich kann gerade nicht nachgucken.
So, ArisOut, du kannst bei mir auf YouTube gucken, da habe ich ein Video gemacht zum neuen Rechner.
Siehe mal Leute, ich kann das.
Du kannst bei mir auf dem YouTube Channel gucken, da habe ich die Einzelteile gezeigt vom neuen Rechner.
monka shake ist das
das ist richtig monka shake hier
gleich brennt er sich durch den boden durch
seh ich schon kommen
aber hier jetzt ist jetzt ist der prime abgekackt auf core 3 100 pro
Jupp also wenn prime abkackt
weil er sich verrechnet ist schon mal kein gutes zeichen
also mit 4,8 geht net 4,8 geht nicht
ich werde jetzt eine sache noch mal probieren ich mache jetzt den offset noch
einen ticken höher setz den offset wieder mal auf 100 und dann probieren wir noch
mal 4,8 aus aber das dürfte echt das fast schon das maximum sein was was geht
da werde ich vielleicht mache ich das doch vielleicht mache ich doch oben die
kappe ab ich gucke mir mal ein paar guides an wie das ganze funktioniert
was gibt es denn außer prime noch für test tools was nimmt man da sonst noch
ich kenne nur prime warum setzt du auf luft nicht auf wasserkühlung ja ich bin
kein fan von wasserkühlung aber muss dazu sagen ich glaube wasserkühlung
würde mir auch hier überhaupt nichts bringen wenn es daran liegt dass die
wärme quasi aus der cpu nicht schnell genug an den deckel kommt wo dann der
lüfter drauf sitzt dann ist fast egal ob das eine wasserkühlung drauf ist oder
an der luftkühlung
das habe ich mir schon gedacht du machst die kappe ab machst halt dann
irgendwas anderes rein als diese kacke wärmerlein passte und dann machst du die
kappe wieder drauf so also so ähnlich spielte schon leicht
weil wo willst du den kühler sonst drauf machen also das habe ich mir schon so
gedacht so zu mal hier was ist für
wieviel spannung das jetzt drauf hat gleich wenn man prime anschmeißen
und bämen
jetzt schon mal gleich richtig rauf 1,3 1 2 ok die spanung da oben stimmt das
heißt dann brauchen wir dieses tool nicht auch noch zusätzlich es wird
verdammt warm
es wird verdammt warm mal gucken ich lasse ich lasse den jetzt mal kurz laufen
mal schauen ob der 4,8 packt
ne packt er nicht
er ist recht dann so abgekackt gerade
press f
ne da geht nicht allzu viel also ich werde da wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
mehr spanung drauf geben müssen und das wird mit der temperatur definitiv nicht
so mit dem lüfter drauf so ich muss wieder entferntaste fingern
einfach recht in den kühlschrank stellen wahrscheinlich wird noch nicht mal das
was bringen wenn die wärme nicht gescheit rauskommt
so ich muss jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr spannung drauf geben müssen und das
stellen wahrscheinlich wird noch nicht mal das was bringen wenn die wärme nicht
gescheit rauskommt
bämen ne scheiß drauf machen wir jetzt nicht ich meine das ding das ding ist
jetzt schon am temperatur mäßig geht jetzt schon immer viel aber mich reizt
ja quasi hier noch mal ein bisschen was drauf zu hauen und gucken ob 4,8 gehen
ich weiß nicht ich mein passieren kann eigentlich nix
mach eher weniger spanung ja das denke ich auch wir machen wieder wir machen
wieder runter und stellen es auf 4,7 und gut ist oder wir können ja noch mal
gucken ob es mit
wie gesagt die temperatur die du mal prime 95 bekommst hast du sonst nichts
ja das stimmt aber dafür kann man sich sicher sein wenn das ordentlich mit
prime läuft dann geht es einfach
also ich zum beispiel ja wenn man testet ob ram kaputt ist da bringt es ja auch
nichts wenn du den test zwei minuten laufen lässt und sagt hey ist es alles
gut die musste auch noch weiter laufen lassen und mal das ram ordentlich
schreiben lesen schreiben lesen auswerten auch wenn das wahrscheinlich
meistens bei normalen program überhaupt keine fehler verursacht aber dementsprechend
finde ich nicht verkehrt dass hier mit prime zu testen
aber der part mit standard spanung läuft 4,7 nicht richtig haben wir ausprobiert
das hatten wir gerade ausprobiert ich hat es ja hier wieder auf die folgt
gesetzt mit 4,7 macht er nicht
also ich glaube das ist so hier das das maximum was wir haben
ups habe ich habe ich habe ich die detakt den tag wieder runter gestellt
es gibt noch andere settings ja ok das das mag sein aber ich habe keine ahnung welche
so 47 und also ich meine was wir machen können ist das ganze vielleicht ein
bisschen realistischer erstmal wir könnten mal hier dieses diese avx ratio
runtersetzen weil anscheinend prime da recht gut reinhaut cash ratio
runtersetzen ich glaube nicht dass das damit was zu tun hat
können die cash ratio mal runtersetzen aber das glaube ich nicht dass es ich
lasse es jetzt erst mal ich lasse es jetzt auf 47 und das wollte ich lasse
jetzt mal auf 70 das sah nämlich so sah nämlich eben so aus als läuft damit
halbwegs gescheit
noch mal kurz prime an
dann schaue ich mir mal an wie man das so macht wir können gucken wir gucken
uns jetzt mal kurz zusammen wir suchen uns jetzt mal in den youtube video
raus in der zeit lassen wir mal prime laufen
bäm
der lüfter der lüfter
kreuer das geht richtig ab
gucken wir mal
was der ab der doch bestimmt youtube channel oder youtube wir gucken uns
jetzt an wie das geht wie man wie man eine cpu köpft gucken wir uns jetzt an
hier vom profi der muss das wissen wo gibt es ein video zu
zeig her ist es doch das hatten wir doch gerade video video gucken wir uns jetzt
noch mal gucken wir uns noch mal fertig an wie wie geht es dann weiter wie geht
es dann weiter das haben wir uns ja gerade schon mal angeguckt
so macht er das da rein macht es ab und nun jetzt erklärt er dass man
wahrscheinlich da was anderes rein machen dann macht man es wieder drauf
und dann wird festgepresst ok das kriege ich gebacken das kriege ich
gebacken was was genau macht man da jetzt rein
hier hier ist ein bisschen ausführlicher noch
hier hier hat das ab schon oder steckt es jetzt da rein macht er
dings ist noch die alte version von dem teil aber das ist ja wurscht
so und jetzt jetzt hat das ab so jetzt jetzt putzt er die kackwärme
leitpaste runter ganzen bist weg und du
jetzt kratzt er noch den rest ab das kann ich dann auch machen und nun
war btf und jetzt kratze jetzt noch die restliche restlichen
dreck von vorher runter ok
was ist das das thermal chrisley das ist ein gesponsertes ding
geht bestimmt aber was anderes
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was jetzt kommt
das ist das ist die special wärmeleitpaste
ok
butterstäbchen verstehe
so wie heißt das ding das thermal chrisley was es nicht alles gibt
hallo wo ist das shopping tab also wir sind auf bing warum sind wir denn auf bing weil es
microsoft ist das thermal chrisley bei amazon aha das zeug das kratzt ja nicht viel kann
man ja kann man sich ja mal gönnen sommer chrisley so was wird das mit
watte stipp mit watte stippchen da drauf gemacht und jetzt gibt es was silikon dass
es besser pappt oder wie vermute vermute mal dass besser pappt ich werde es bei meiner cpu
nicht machen ganz ehrlich das ding hat genug genug leistung ich werde es erst machen wenn
ich die möglichkeit habe eine zweite einen zweiten 8700 k zu kriegen ich habe keinen bock
meine cpu jetzt zu schrotten oder mit neuen rechnern dazu stehen wo für ich keine cpu
habe ok jetzt hat er das zeug da drauf und jetzt wird es drauf geklebt
das macht eigentlich so unser prime im hintergrund läuft noch und ist heiß die cpu was gibt es
noch außer prime 95 noch für noch für tests testprogramm mit dem man das testen kann die
vielleicht ein bisschen realistischer dran sind an an an dem load den man bei dem game
hat kennt da jemand was weil game kann ich jetzt nicht laufen lassen real bench so jetzt
jetzt wird das ganze wahrscheinlich einfach wieder drauf geklebt das probiere ich mal
aus wenn ich die möglichkeit habe einen zweiten 8700 k zu bekommen falls ich das ding irgendwie
schrotten sollte das habe ich mir vorhin schon mal runtergeladen da ist ein test dabei
ja prime 95 haben wir noch die ganze zeit benutzt so wie ist das was real bench warum
benutze ich überhaupt diesen kack browser also asus asus wie das ja richtig heißt
asus
asus hat gesagt sie finden asus ok anscheinend heißt das wirklich so und asus finden sie
auch ok was sie nicht ok finden ist die englische aussprache von aces aces finden sie beschissen
hat mal einer erzählt von asus wie hast du denn wie hast du den 8700 k bekommen ich
habe bei vielen shops vorbestellt und hatte glück ich habe bei mulis tag vorbestellt
asus real bench probieren wir das mal damit aus nein das chip install chip installer alter
ich will gibt mir doch nicht so eine scheiße ich will einfach das programm haben real bench
kann sie nicht einfach den download link mal dazu geben real bench computer bild gibt
sie einfach mal den download dazu vielleicht hat heise sowas
ja komm dann nein nein nicht nicht von chip laden wir uns alles hier runter meinetwegen
so
klick auf manuell bar chip allein schon dass das nötig ist ist ja schon wieder lächerlich
probieren wir das noch mal aus real bench wenn das näher an spielen dran ist den probieren
wir auch noch mal aus da habe ich jetzt den probieren wir auch noch mal aus was manueller
download soll ich machen manuell chip please soll in der scheiß kann es so echt nicht
sein dass sie dann dass sie quasi jetzt noch schon aufpassen muss dass sie dir beinahe
eigentlich sonst ziemlich legit seite zumindest was download an downloads anbelangt so vom
technischen inhalt her kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten ok aber dass man da jetzt
schon aufpassen muss dass man nicht sich in die scheiße einfängt ist schon hart ja cheat
das sehe ich auch so ein ordentlicher paket manager für windows für alles nicht nicht
dieser kacke wieder windows store ja wo eh nix drinne ist ein ordentlicher paket manager
weil ich habe jetzt schon keinen bock ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt für den rechner
hier wieder 20 verschiedene treiber installieren dass alles funktioniert und die müsste man
ja eigentlich auch aktuell halten was man halt öfters mal nicht macht sein bench oder
auch oder auch der scene bench so machen wir mal prime aus wie warm ist es ziemlich warm
prime läuft noch jawoll passt alles alles geht also anscheinend sind wir zumindest halbwegs
stable auf diesem takt mit offset 0,7 0,0 0,07 gut da war jetzt mal den real bench
zack alles zu der real bench hat mein leben noch nicht nicht einmal real bench ausgeführt
ist ein cute programm spricht schon mal für die qualität wobei origin ist auch ein cute
programm allerdings mit embedded browser das ist die benutzen von cute eigentlich gar nichts
außer den browser der asus real bench stresstest machen wir 15 kann man kann man nicht weniger
machen start was ja ich habe ja keinen grafikkarten treiber drauf ich dachte jetzt nicht dass
ich für den cpu testen grafikkarten treiber braucht warum brauche ich für den cpu test
eigentlich den grafikkarten treiber prime anhalten ich habe prime ausgemacht wahrscheinlich
muss ich den kram einfach einfach ausmachen super ok dann war sie ein bench sein bench
auch schon das letzte mal vor keine ahnung vor ewigkeiten ausgeführt was kann man jetzt
aktuell aussieht nein cpu ran wir wollen nicht wir wollen keine wir wollen keine test
für grafikkarten machen das funktioniert nämlich nicht ich habe noch gar keinen grafikkarten
treiber installiert da flitze da da flitze da ja er zieht nicht ganz so viel wie unter
prime aber das ist das war ja zu erwarten alles flutscht
aber hier beim nummer eins kann man kann er nicht noch mehr testen kann hat er nicht
noch mehr tests cpu ok mal single core test noch mal
da ist ganze ganze ecke langsamer da sieht man mal das macht ordentlich was aus dass
das ist ein riesen unterschied das ist ein riesen unterschied der single core zu multithread
aber man ist klar dafür ist es ja auch da kann man das abbrechen
so als vergleichen wir das mal wie das somit mit anderen scene bench results 8700 k
wo ist er denn ja passt doch
passt doch wir haben bisschen übertaktet dementsprechend sind wir jetzt so auf diesem
niveau hier also wir sind übertaktet ungefähr auf dem niveau von von einem reisen mit wohlgemerkt
zwei kehren weniger also das das hört sich realistisch an das hört sich doch echt realistisch
an finde ich gut doch ordentlich
das ist ja geil der da ist das da wäre ich jetzt von ausgegangen dass die ganzen die
ganzen reisen eigentlich oder fast fast alle reisen schneller sind zumindest halt die mit
acht kerne weil sie haben halt einfach mal zwei kerne mehr und das ist bei tests oder
bei benchmarks die halt super parallel laufen oder parallelisieren parallelisierte tests
haben machen es halt die zwei kerne schon ordentlich aus single core beziehungsweise
so single thread performance werden wir mit dem hier wahrscheinlich eine ganze ecke schneller
viel schneller als den reisen ja aber so alles in allem kann ich damit leben ich meine das
ding hat jetzt wir haben eben nur ein bisschen mehr spannung gegeben nicht viel mehr weil
es halt auch gar nicht geht wegen der kühlung und wir haben jetzt quasi den single also
den turbotakt den er normalerweise verwendet wenn nur ein kern belastet ist haben wir jetzt
für alle kerne das ist doch ok ich meine man könnte jetzt natürlich in in das noch
mal in das in das bios vom board gehen und da einstellen dass man also wenn jetzt wenn
jetzt irgendwie beispielsweise guckt man also der der sechser wenn jetzt halt irgendein
kern besonders besonders warm werden sollte von denen hier da könnte man jetzt im uefi
ja noch einstellen dass quasi für diesen kern andere andere andere andere takt verwendet
wird und sowas aber ganz ehrlich ist uns ja nicht übertreiben
das hoch und runter takten funktioniert auch noch machen wir noch mal ein prime an
jetzt geht er gleich wieder hoch auf seine paar 90
marvin fragt ob die alten sehens mit 10 oder 12 kann nicht noch besser sein also ich sehe
uns in erst mal saumäßig teuer und je nachdem wie alt der ist falls dann überhaupt so alte
12 kein sehens gibt die billig sind dann sind die wahrscheinlich von der architektur her
auch nicht mehr die tau sind nicht mehr so tau frisch und wenn wahrscheinlich auch nicht
viel schneller sein zumal man ja dafür dann auch das passende bord brauchen die schlucken
strom wie sau also wahrscheinlich fährste dann mit einem thread ripper auf jeden fall
besser wenn du denn so viele kerne brauchst
was hältst du eigentlich vor der namensgebung der aktuell amd und intel chipsetze sowas
von bescheuert warum warum z370 und x370 warum wird die cpu noch geköpft wahrscheinlich
der akte wahrscheinlich allerdings erst wenn wieder 8.700 k cpus lieferbar sind weil ich
will mir den nicht kaputt machen weil ich nicht aufpasse und dann habe ich einen neuen
rechner und alles und toll und super und ich habe gerne cpu für crazy sie ich würde
sagen fast ich würde sagen fast also man könnte jetzt noch mal eins eins runter gehen
und gucken ob es noch stabil läuft aber ich glaube das lasse ich erstmal so den nächsten
versuch gibt es dann wieder wenn noch mehr 8.700 lieferbar sind und ich wirklich mal
versuche oben die platte abzumachen und das ding zu köpfen und wenn es dann wirklich
viel kühler bleibt dann werde ich da auch noch ein bisschen nach oben gehen machst du
beruflich was mit der it ja mache ich allerdings keine cpus köpfen und auch nicht übertakten
ich kümmere mich um unsere software verwaltung könnte man so sagen also quasi also nicht
um software verwaltung also nicht in form von was wo installiert wird sondern source
code verwaltung so rum source code verwaltung und das ein oder andere programmier ich auch
noch selbst allerdings kümmere ich mich hauptsächlich unsere source code verwaltung lohnt es sich
für die programmieren was jeno hdx fragt lohnt es sich für programmieren auf linux
umzusteigen oder lohnt sich linux für admin netzwerkzeug naja kommt darauf an was du programmieren
willst also wenn du jetzt wpf machen möchtest unter windows dann natürlich nicht oder wenn
du uwp apps für windows store und windows machen willst dann dann auch nicht und das
kommt doch an was du machen willst ja wenn du jetzt beispielsweise was richtung web
entwicklung machst da ist linux eine super arbeitsumgebung dafür und was sowas wie netzwerk
anbelangt und was sachen ausprobieren sowas da ist linux eh meilenweit vorne vor windows
es gibt ich habe ja schon mal ein video drüber gemacht zu dieser ganze linux versus windows
debatte beide systeme haben einfach ganz klar ihre stärken aber in komplett unterschiedlichen
gebieten auch auch wenn man da jetzt noch neck dabei nimmt das hat auch seine stärken
alles läuft läuft noch alles neckl ist dann auch eindeutig seine stärken in früher hätte
ich gesagt in audio und video und natürlich weil immer noch ein ziemlich unix ähnliches
system drunter ist was auch sehr praktisch ist sprich das meiste linux zeug die meisten
tools laufen auch ohne probleme und unter merck us aktuell würde ich sagen den vorteil
zwisch für video weiß ich nicht wie groß da noch ist beim meck würde ich sagen da
nimmt sich wahrscheinlich windows und meck gar nicht mehr so viel es gibt mittlerweile
sogar gescheite unter linux gescheite videoschnittprogramme und video bearbeitungsprogramme also richtig
profiprogramme die gut funktionieren wo ich sagen würde wo meck noch seine vorteile hat
im kreativen bereich ist audio bearbeitung das ist unter windows und graus wenn man eben
also jetzt nicht die eigentliche audio bearbeitung an sich die geht unter windows auch aber das
so dass das auto das routing von von eingabequellen und keine ahnung an audio interface dran und
möchte beispielsweise so was wie so was wie man was einer quasi in der regie macht so
du hast verschiedene eingabequellen und möchtest dann eben diese sache dahin leiten und das
ist das ist unter windows alles kacke das ist unter meck viel schöner es hat alles
seine vornachteile die stärken von linux sehe ich eindeutig im bereich von netzwerk web und
solchen geschichten zwar unabhängig davon dass man das einsatz auf dem server und sowas
ich rede jetzt nur für quasi für anwender also sprich wenn man etwas richtung webentwicklung
macht wenn man sich wenn man irgendwelche sachen debunken muss wenn man netzwerk technisch
gucken muss was was passiert da was ist da los und solche sachen und vor allem auch
leute die gerne auf der kommando zeile arbeiten die werden unter linux glücklich leute die
spielen wollen werden eindeutig weder unter meck noch unter linux wirklich glücklich
unter meck noch eher als unter linux da bleibt eigentlich nur windows gibt gibt einfach keine
alternative zu wenn man spielen will außer eben eine konsole das war jetzt ja aber nicht
war der diskussion dabei also konsolen geht immer aber wenn man spielen will fährt jeder
lino geht an den windows nichts vorbei es gibt ein paar hacks immer manche sachen doch
unter linux zum laufen zu bekommen das funktioniert mehr schlecht als recht beispielsweise funktioniert
auf erwatsch ansatzweise unter linux aber der maussteiger hat probleme wenn man springt
glaube ich steht da glaube ich manchmal in der hocke gestackt und lootboxen sind durchsichtig
irgendwie so kommen es ist halt ziemlich kaputt und wenn man multiplayer spielt und das quasi
auf eine nicht support plattform macht dann könnte das für den anti cheat schutz schon
mal aussehen als hätte man in den programm eingeklickt würde bescheißen obwohl man das
eigentlich gar nicht macht also spielen bleibt eigentlich nur windows oder halt eine konsole
so und wenn man da hat der eiskolter natürlich recht wenn man für windows entwickelt dann
braucht man windows genauso wie wenn man für ios oder mac os entwickelt braucht man zwingend
gar keine chance braucht man einen mac wenn man für windows entwickelt und jetzt nicht
gerade universal apps oder sowas oder wpf anwendung oder sowas erstellen will wenn man wenn es
jetzt mal so sagen wir irgendwie cc plus plus anwendung ist mit irgendeinem cross platform
framework das kann man auch unter linux für windows kompilieren das funktioniert da braucht
man kein windows umgedreht geht das mittlerweile angeblich auch ich habe es bloß noch nicht
ausprobiert also gehen müsste das theoretisch schon immer aber ich glaube mittlerweile ist
es angeblich viel einfacher durch diese durch dieses windows windows vor linux vor windows
zeug so ich muss mal kurz gucken ich habe irgendwelche fragen überlesen so wir lassen
jetzt das prime noch ein bisschen laufen ist der test abgekackt der test ist abgekackt
das ist schlecht das ist schlecht ist es doch nicht so stable wie man wie wir uns das gedacht
haben das ist schlecht welcher kern ist das 7 das ist core nummer ja welcher core ist
das jetzt 6 cpu core 6 der um spackt das muss man alles noch mal angucken in ruhe
kann man das irgendwie wegschieben so ob das andere wenigstens ordentlich weiter läuft
ist immer noch heiß wie sau
versuch mal den turbotakt im bios auf alle kerne zu forsen das
ich glaube das funktioniert doch nicht sobald man irgendwas einstellt oder wie war das
gucken wir mal das können wir uns noch mal angucken
das das probieren wir noch mal schnell was jeno hdx fragt was hältst du von java finde
das mit den verschiedenen jdk version etc so nervig zu benutzen wieso wird einfach an
der uni sowas beigebracht java ist einfach verbreitet vor allem im business umfeld und
wenn man android anwendung programmieren will ich bin auch kein java fan das wisst ihr also
nilsson meinst du sowas also quasi auf auto stellen und dann sagen multicore enhancement
das wird nicht funktionieren dann dann dann dann taktet auch trotzdem runter auf 4,3 also ich
würde vermuten der taktet jetzt trotzdem runter auf 4,3 weil ja dieses zeug hier nach wie vor
in takt ist man kann ja specific parkour das finde ich cool man könnte dann quasi hier sagen
sowas wie 47 47 47 47 47 47 und der 46 so nach dem auto das finde ich das ist ein cooles setting
es gefällt mir mal was mal so auto probieren was daraus kommt jetzt so aus gibt meint ich
lese mir nur die fragen kann man durch ich mache aber erst mal prime an
ne koch das taktet runter das das bringt nix
so frage gab eine frage eben noch habe ich gesehen im chat
kenny west eins wie lernt man eigentlich am besten programmieren also ich meine wenn man
das einfach nebenbei als hobby machen will einfach anfangen einfach anfangen du suchst
dir eine sprache du du suchst dir am besten was draus was du machen willst ich finde so
lernt man das immer am besten ich starte mal nebenbei neue sucht ja was draus was du
machen willst also falls du irgendwie du hattest ja wahrscheinlich die idee so hey warum gibt
es dieses diese sorte software nicht warum gibt es das und das und ich mich könnte das
selbst programmieren vielleicht bist du aus diesem grund auf die idee gekommen damit anzufangen
dann überlegt ja was soll das den können worauf soll das laufen web anwendung eine
desktop anwende oder sowas und dann suchst du dir was raus was dafür gut passt was zum
beispiel ganz praktisch ist man bleibt einfach auf der plattform wo man eben standardmäßig
auch schon unterwegs ist also wenn du windows user bist dann installierst du dir einfach
mal studio community edition und bastelst ein bisschen mit schaab rum fängst du erstmal
mit konsolen anwendung vielleicht die ein oder andere so mal zum eintritt so ein bisschen
angucken windows forms anwendung und nimmst dir ein ordentliches schaab buch schaab ist
eine super einsteiger programmiersprache unter windows somit das beste finde ich wo man anfangen
kann und dann nimmst du dir ein buch gibt bei openpress galileo oder wie das früher hieß
gibt es ein super sie schaab einsteiger buch was hältst du von der sprache rust finde
ich super finde ich sieht absolut hässlich aus was wirklich richtig hässlich aber finde
ich von vom ansatz her und der idee her finde ich das ist eine sehr gute sache
dass wir immer auf 44 stehen den machen wir noch mal ein hoch nochmal um zu gucken ob
es jetzt sable läuft wie findest du python zum einstieg auch gut python ist auch eine
super einsteiger programmiersprache das problem ist unter windows da fühlt sich dieses da
fühlt sich die meisten programmiersprachen halt nicht so richtig zu hause wie unter linux
also so war ich rede jetzt von sowas wie python ruby und sowas klar es gibt eine windows version
keine funktioniert aber das profitiert also diese ganzen dynamischen sprachen sowie python
ruby das profitiert schon davon wenn man mal ein ordentliches terminal fenster hat eine
ordentliche konsole hat wo man dann auch mal ein bisschen was schnell drin ausprobieren kann und so das
fühlt sich unter windows einfach nicht nicht so rund an wenn man nicht davor zurückschreckt
sich in linux zu installieren beziehungsweise linux vm das ist dann auch eine super gelegenheit
um sich mal sowas wie bash anzugucken sprich linux shell und unix shell sich python anzugucken
ruby anzugucken das sind auch super einsteiger programmiersprachen und was zum einsteigen
natürlich auch gut ist muss man ehrlicherweise sagen ist ja was kippt weil halt browser gibt es
halt überall und ist auf jeden fall sehr gefragt das ist ja sommerlich hier die temperatur
ewoli c und c++ hat mit c-sharp auch wenig zu tun also meiner ansicht der dinge das hat
das hat microsoft nur c-sharp genannt weil es halt im kopf der leute quasi so c, c++,
c-sharp kommen sollte es hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten von der synthaxe mit den klammern und sowas ja
es ist es ist schon eine sprache so im c style aber trotzdem ganz anders
flip4games nein ich habe die cpu noch nicht geköpft das mache ich aber allerdings erst
wenn es wieder mehr cpus gibt weil ich will das ding nicht schrotten und da habe ich einen rechner
stehen mit allem drum und dran und kann ihn nicht benutzen weil cpu kaputt
die temps sind etwas hoch ach
wie viel volt liegen da nicht so viel die temperaturen sind
saumäßig hoch also meine cpu bleibt nicht kühl deswegen ich ich werde das mit dem köpfen
wahrscheinlich machen mich würde es jetzt ja reizen dass gleich direkt mir quasi die
wärmeleitpassung das zeug dafür zu holen und quasi sobald sobald ich hab das ding deckel ab
zack rein deckel drauf würde ich ja machen aber realistisch betrachtet ist es besser
mal so rational überlegt es ist besser ich warte bis es cpus lieferbar gibt bevor ich
jetzt doch irgendwie die cpu dabei schrotte und dann habe ich einen rechner mit dem ich
nichts machen kann 215 watt ist aber wo hast du das gesehen steht das hier das haut rein
ja das haut rein
hast du schon was zu linux subsystem aktuell bin aus gesagt ne habe ich auch
nix zu gesagt es ist jetzt aber stable das einzige was ich dazu gelesen habe
kann man das eigentlich mittlerweile einfach so ins instagram
ach nee das ist ja das ist ja die windauslogik feature feature hinzufügen
muss man ja jetzt machen wo war das noch mal hier feature feature hinzufügen
mannatsch mannatsch feature nee fack add feature wo wo wo wo fack wo hat man das
teub noch mal hinzugefügt
ich habe schon wieder ganz vergessen wo man die kram überhaupt installiert
mannatsch optional features nee ich weiß gar nicht was in der alten systemsteuerung
ernsthaft dazu muss man in die alte systemsteuerung was meinst du wo gibt's
mehr besser besser bei hardware software oder unter koch videos unter koch videos
sehe ich eigentlich wenig besser besser also ich gucke ja ich gucke relativ viel
food content auf youtube da sind die leute eigentlich relativ nett
zueinander
hier geht das genau so da konnte man jetzt irgendwie windows windows subsystem
vor linux konnte man da installieren und da hatten wir windows features was ich
richtig richtig behindert finde ist tell net client hallo ein windows feature
enthält klein nennen 15 kb großes programm da einfach standardmäßig
mal mit hinlegen ich weiß ja nicht was mit microsoft los ist warum das als
extra windows feature durchgeht ja ich weiß aber noch nicht ob ich mir
installieren werde wieder weil ich habe da gar nicht so großartig
anwendungszweck für muss ich ehrlich sagen
ich habe meine linux vm die brauche ich auch weil ich will ich will grafische
linux programe verwenden ich weiß das geht auch mit diesem mit
diesem windows subsystem für linux wenn man sich in xserver in xserver und
winos installiert aber wirklich schön ist das alles nicht habe ich meine
winos vm meine linux vm und ansonsten also ich habe jetzt wenig anwendungszweck
dafür ehrlich gesagt ffm pack und sowas verwende ich das was es für
winos gibt zum zum videos entkonen
wenn du die cpu köpfst ist die garantie weg ja deswegen will ich erwarten bis
es wieder lieferbar gibt weil wenn ich das ding schrotten sollte
dann will ich wenigstens ersatz haben für mein rechner
treco b ich habe vorhin extra prime 27 9 oder so runter geladen
weil das wohl weniger cpu zieht und auch kein avx verwendet es könnte aber auch
sein dass das 27 neu war vielleicht weißt du das ja dann lade ich das alte
noch mal runter
mit wie vielen course beziehungsweise ram nutz deine fremde ich glaube ram habe
ich dem ding 6 riga bald gegeben und cpu kerne klaut 3 oder so das flutscht
linux in der vm läuft super form vor immer workstation kann auch für box
nehmen wenn man kein bock hat sich vor immer workstation zu kaufen
an meinem modem kommen laut test 100 mit an endgeräten 10 mit was mit was es
der link also sprich was wird angezeigt am endgerät oder guckt ihr mal die
farben von dem lichtchen an am port was der für eine geschwindigkeit anzeigt
vielleicht zünkt er ja nur mit 10 dann ist kein wunder das nur 10 ankommt
wenn aus warum warum linux fremme das ist eine gute frage warum den linux vm
und nicht quasi dual boot oder auf dem zweiten rechner das liegt daran weil ich
gerne mit windows und linux parallel arbeite und ich kann bock hab zum
rebooten für zum spielen quasi rebooten zu müssen
linux vm ist für mich der beste kompromisse da draus
und einen zweiten rechner extra dafür quasi hinstellen
dann müsste ich ja quasi auf den anderen monitor gucken ich habe zwar
einen zweiten monitor hier stehen und auch einen zweiten rechner aber da brauche
ich zum beispiel auch in windows drauf für unter anderem capture card und
mittlerweile brauche ich da gar nicht unbedingt mehr windows drauf bräuchte
ich theoretisch nicht aber das ist den rechner den ich immer während dem
stream an hab auf dem zweiten monitor um mir sachen anzugucken von denen ich
sichergehen will dass sie definitiv nicht im stream erscheinen
zum beispiel mein settings page von twitch und und der follower stream
der follower notifications und so zeug und die donations und so was das könnte
ich mal mit linux angucken aber für mich ist so vom vom workflow
her ist am besten linux vm da habe ich das parallel und ganz ehrlich linux in
der vm das ist super schnell das einzige was was man nicht machen kann sind
videos gucken in der vm also das geht aber verbraucht verbraucht ziemlich viel
cpu leistung weil man halt kein hardware decoder von der grafikkarte in der vm
hat also mit 4k videos von island gucken auf youtube in der vm im browser ist
nicht was hältst du davon dass es extrem viele anwendungen heute gibt mit ja die
mit html und javascript geschrieben werden grausam ganz schlimm kann doch
nicht sein dass ich für ein publisches programm einen halben gigabyte ram oder
gigabyte ram brauche ganz schlimm und ehrlich so was wie spotify das muss keine
javascript browser anwendung sein ganz ehrlich muss es nicht musik player
gibt seit 20 jahren die funktionieren es gibt musik player die brauchen
wahrscheinlich 3 mb ram und sind beim download 500 kilobyte groß das muss nicht
sein ich verstehe warum man es macht ja es geht schneller zu entwickeln das
senkt bestimmt auch die kosten wenn man eine anwendung für alles hat aber ich
finde es ganz schlimm dass es so viele übertrieben aufgeblasene anwendung
mittlerweile gibt auf dem rechner weil die hersteller zu faul sind was auch
anderes zu programmieren ja man ist schneller man hat vielleicht das
produkt schneller fertig wenn man das irgendwie mit mit elektron oder so macht
also sprich quasi einen browser ausliefert mit einem also ein fenster
mit einem browser drin und da drin dann alles mit html und css macht aber
überlegt euch mal du hast den bettel net launcher laufen du hast origin laufen
du hast steam laufen du hast den was weiß ich den gog launcher oder so laufen
oder so solche programme in in der in der richtung das sind alles absolut mega
aufgeblähte dinger für das was sie machen
aber wenn man nicht kann es euch leider jetzt nicht zeigen ich habe sie nicht
installiert das sind alles keine richtigen gesture programme mehr das sind
alles quasi in den fenster mit einem chrome drin bettel net client origin steam
das ist alles in den fenster mit einem chrome drin und da ist alles web das
braucht dementsprechend auch massig ram und auch mehr cpu als es eigentlich
bräuchte finde ich ganz schlimm diesen trend
hast du noch irgendwelche besonderen anpassungen an deiner vm gemacht für
bessere performance ich habe dem ding ordentlich ram gegeben
ich habe dem ding ordentlich ram gegeben ich habe dem ding ordentlich cpu kerne
gegeben es liegt auf einer ssd drauf die vm dass das auch wichtig das flutscht
ja eiskäuter so geht es mir auch ich würde am liebsten auch hauptsächlich
linux verwenden also nur linux verwenden aber es gibt halt viele
sachen die ich gerne mache nur für winnows
also das wegen der winnows das wegen der linux vm dann habe ich quasi beides
parallel das ist das beste beste was gibt für mich die kombination ja aber
also 3d sachen in der vm ist es alles sehr holprig das funktioniert teilweise
aber teilweise auch nicht also schön ist es nicht sparks development fragt
welche vm verwendest du und was sagst du zur open vz virtualisieren das ist eine
gute frage also für meine vms auf dem desktop verwende ich vor allem bei
workstation auf meinem server für die für die vms verwende ich einmal kvm
also für voll virtualisierte vms kvm und für container lxc und open vz ist ja
eher was richtung so was wie linux container quasi die linux container
bevor es linux container gab open vz open vz ist ja keine wirkliche
voll virtualisierte vm quasi linux kernel mit ein paar patches
drin dass man prozesse besser voneinander isolieren kann also das was
heute lxc ist und was mit mit als mit docker als frontend total der hype ist
zur zeit wobei ich kein fan von docker bin aber
von linux container aber nicht von docker
was willst du übertacken ich habe meinen mein cbo hier im stream
übertackt leider wie du siehst hier die temperatur x ethics ist schon ziemlich
ausgereizt
da geht nicht so viel mehr
guck mal was cpo 6 und 7 da machen die machen
ich gehe mal davon aus dass windows weil ich sie so rum eitel dass windows
im hintergrund dinger tut weil es läuft alles es läuft alles alles ok alles am
loch hat man gar nicht gesehen eben
unstable bähm also meine cpu lässt sich grotten schlecht übertacken richtig
treu dich
richtig schlecht er ist hier 6 und sieben spack drum
das heißt ich müsste dem ding jetzt noch eine runde mehr spannung spendieren
dass es sogar nur 4,7 ordentlich schafft das doch der witz also ok was heißt
das ist der witz ja man ist aber so man kauft die für 3,7 beziehungsweise 4,3
mit einem core 4,7 also das ist immer noch mehr als die spezifikation von dem
ding auch nur ansatzweise also da kann man sich jetzt nicht wirklich
beschweren drüber aber dass die ihre kacke damit wärmeleitpasta machen da kann
man schon drüber beschweren ja die temperatur ist krass hier guck
schnittel watz muss man sich mal angucken ja das ist lächerlich
guck da ja hat hat sich verrechnet das ding gefällt hallo eschen denn ich habe
mir folgerwerkstation lizenz gekauft richtig regenwolf ich verwende stadt
stocker lxc 2 von ubuntu es gibt auch noch ein paar andere sachen ich bin aber
von docker allgemein docker ist so ein riesen aufgeblähtes ding mittlerweile und
ist ja auch nicht für was ich den starten von eins von von quasi ganzen
ganz lilox system gedacht im container sondern eigentlich nur für einzelne
prozesse was auch viele leute bis hin missbrauchen
bis zu welcher temperatur gibt es der cpu denn gut naja im prinzip bis zu der
cp bis zu der temperatur wo sie runter regelt also irgendwas um die 100 grad
das ist halt schon krass war mir
welches prime hat freund noch mal einer geschrieben soll ich mir ziehen 26 6 oder
so ziehen wir uns das noch mal das ist jetzt das prime ohne avx oder wie das
heißt
von 2011 btf
ich habe freunde workstation was hast du für die workstation version gekauft was
fremder hat es gibt nur eine version von fremder workstation es gibt halt fremder
workstation es heißt also
hallo dort die päpsel aber doch der fremder player ist kostenlos der
fremder player ist kostenlos fremder workstation kostet was gibt es aber
immer mal wieder aktion und ich finde das lohnt sich für ein fremder workstation
ist so das rundeste was es gibt für desktop virtualisierung
na und dass der jetzt nicht stabil gewesen ist auf dem takt mit der
spannung das liegt jetzt auch nicht unbedingt an der kühlung oder so sondern
weil er wahrscheinlich einfach noch ein bisschen mehr spannung gebraucht hätte
die ich ihm aber nicht geben kann ohne dass es zu warm wird
das mit dem prime test bleibt es natürlich die ganze ecke kühler weil
er noch nicht so die special instruktion verwendet die cpu zum kochen
bringen hallo offfisch
dein name ist grad hellgrün auf weiß ich kann das nicht richtig lesen
off official key os
dort die päpsel das smile cpu funktioniert nicht geht nicht richtig also
das wird übel heiß wenn ich das mit aktuellen prime mache und im prinzip ist
so mit dieser kühlung würde ich mal sagen bei also bei 4,7 ist wahrscheinlich
sogar schon schluss
wenn ich nicht die spanung noch viel weiter höhere könnte ich machen ja aber
das mache ich erst wenn ich dann auch noch eine ersatz cpu habe und oben den
deckel abmachen kann also man sieht mit dieser prime version bleibt natürlich
schon eine ganze ecke kühler
snowbier 122 fragt was macht vmw workstation pro im vergleich zu oracle
wirtel box besser max also funktionieren tut beides aber ich finde ich finde
bedienung her irgendwie irgendwie runder von der ganzen oberfläche von den
forever tools von den snapshots wie was wie was anlegen kann mir gefällt es
einfach besser damals mal so viertel box ist nicht schlecht selbst im
wasserkühlung wird mir jetzt hier nicht allzu viel bringen wenn die wärme von
der cpu nicht direkt auf den nicht schnell genug am deckel hochkommt
machen mal stresstest mit xtu das war aber noch das war mal jetzt noch
das war jetzt noch das gibt es nicht als zipp das muss man installieren
beides hatte ich mir doch vorher schon runter geladen warte mal das ist doch
schon vorher schon mal runter
so lieber den kack mal das intel extreme tuning utility
natürlich da immer noch mal sql server drauf ne emas sql server restart the
fuck warum na gut wenn intel das möchte wie starten wir halt ich weiß auch nicht
warum ich edge immer aufmache ja keine ahnung ich sollte mal den edge button
außen aus der taskleiste raus machen falls ich irgendwelche fragen habe
fragen überlesen habe schreibt es einfach noch mal restart in 2k 17 fack ich
habe irgendwas im auge so wie gehen das ich habe das tooler nicht verwendet
bisher intel extreme tuning utility das hat schon mal geilen namen
offisch official key keys ich habe keine ahnung von aktuellen laptops
nein ich will nicht will nirgendswo teilnehmen ich will einfach das tool
verwenden was kostet die workstation version weiß
ich nicht guck bei vmw weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht aber es gibt manchmal
angebote so an weihnachten rum oftmals was ich als avx offset eingestellt habe
aktuell nichts aktuell läuft das ding ohne ohne gedrosselt zu werden
hi was hat er für komponenten entweder kannst du auf mein youtube channel gehen
und dir das letzte video angucken da zeige ich im detail was ich habe oder es
postet hier man die geiz hals link es gibt nämlich sogar irgendein kommando
für den bot so benchmarking stresstest cpu stresstest 5 minuten start go go
ich war noch mal stopp weil ich will erst mal hardware monitor aufmachen für
temperaturanzeige oder macht es ach nee das macht das das macht das das tut das
tool hier auch zeigt es auch die temperatur an
ja da unten ist er die temperatur wtf easy
null ich würde sagen das inter das inter tool ist nicht so wirklich gut für
ihre eigene cpu das steht nämlich null also sprich ein anderes tool kann besser
inter cpus auslesen wie das inter tool das ist natürlich auch toll
kannst du zeigen wie gut das 10g interface auf dem mainboard ist nee
weil ich das nie angeschlossen haben 10g interface und ich auch kein kabel hab
um an mein cg switch zu kommen von hier gerade kann ich nicht
kann ich gerade nicht zeigen
also der inter stresstest ist ist ja lächerlich im vergleich zu prime
wie übertaktest du also aktuell habe ich den bios oder ein efi ist es ja
mittlerweile eingestellt es gibt auch von von s rock und inter und so gibt es
halt hier auch wenn du aus tools mit dem man das machen kann aber ich finde es
ganz gut erst mal einfach unabhängig im bios bisschen auszuprobieren
da muss man auch keine tools installieren das geht einfach
warum ich den anderen namen habe weil ich ursprünglich nie vorhabe zu
streben als wir das erstellt haben
mach mal den benchmark kann ich machen also stresstest scheint ja zu
funktionieren benchmark mache ich benchmarking
das muss man jetzt noch irgendwie was einstellen außer aus am run benchmark
error benchmarking process has failed
warum warum warum geht das nicht ich starte dieses kakt tool noch mal neu
still running nein ich will nicht dass es still rund
kann aber verpiss dich exit warum geht der benchmark nicht
intel software deswegen installiert so eine kacke normalerweise gar nicht
auch guck mal die temperatur stimmt jetzt auch intel software 2k 17
und gucke und sie an der benchmark funktioniert
ich kann von meiner cpu keine package power auslesen
sagt der snow bier jemand tipps bei jeder auslesen software selbe keine ahnung
vielleicht wird langsam zeit für einen grafik treiber ich installiere
ich installiere da ersten grafikkarten treiber drauf wenn ich die 1080 di drin
habe so ist der benchmark fertig
ok ich habe laut intel 2593 marks intel was ist es für eine scheiß software
kann ich mir noch nicht mal online top liste angucken ohne dass ich mich hier
anmelden muss oder wie ne leute ne da mache ich nicht mit da mache ich nicht
mit so eine kacke was ist denn das
nein geht nicht haben wir keinen bock drauf aber kein bock drauf kann ich
wenigstens die top liste hier irgendwo angucken
gucken wir uns das mal an wir können uns die liste einfach angucken ohne
boar ist die seite wie unübersichtlich ist die seite
eigentlich rangenlisten
ja komm lass mal lass mal ein bisschen ein bisschen realistischere gefilde
wieviel habe ich 2600
wie mehr gibt es nicht
hallo kann ich kann ich ja nicht mal irgendwie vergleichen wie viele ich mit
anderen hab von dem system ich weiß nicht was das für eine kacke anzahl der
kerner 6
krass ich hab eine donation bekommen steaming am an der neuer has donated
heimachse auf hack es ist weg ich ich konnte nicht lesen mein problem ist ich
kann keine donations lesen wenn ich sie nicht im stream sehe weil ich den
zweiten rechner nicht anhab meint ich guck mal ob ich schon ob ich mein stream
schnell aufmachen kann dass ich sie sehe
danke schon mal für die fünf euro ich sehe sie noch nicht mal im stream die
donation ich kann auch kann ich nachgucken das tut mir leid aber kann ich
jetzt leider keine nix machen
heute ich meinen zweiten rechner wo ich normalerweise donations alles donations
und sowas alles offen hab aber wenn er stream gefällt ist super ich hab da
irgendwie sowas rausgelesen kade auf die schnelle
ok gucken wir noch mal hier
ich hab doch auf sechs kerne eingestellt oder habe ich netz sechs kerne
ja guckt die haben alle die gleichen cpu wie ich ungefähr plus halt mehr
takt so dass das passt da bewegen wir uns da bewegen wir uns genau in diesem
guck mal in dat wir werden sogar in der top liste auf platz da werden wir auf
platz 33 vor uns ist nen i7 8700 k mit vier mit 4730 also passt genau
cool hier dass die donation abgetippt hast heimachs ich wollte sagen ich liebe
dich und deine videos ja das höre ich gerne ich freue mich immer wieder wenn
ich was neues von dir sehen meine abo box zum glück funktioniert bei dir die abo
box wann wieder overwatch was ist das für eine intel software
mach weiter so du bist ein er und man lange für die donation das ist das
intel wie heißt das teil das intel extreme tuning utility eigentlich ist es
überhaupt nicht mehr zeitgemäß das intel dieses ding so nennt so was muss
heute intel extreme double sniper fatality pro heißen extreme tuning
utility ist viel zu 015 gott like gott like extreme intel gott like extreme
double shots sniper killer tuning utility das wäre ein guter name
das wäre ein guter name das müssen wir intel vorschlagen so
was passiert eigentlich hat dieses dieses intel dingsbums tool hier schon mal
jemand verwendet und weiß was passieren würde check das denn auch auf fehler
beim stress test weil das schöne bei prime ist ja es checkt fehler wenn die
cpo irgendwie kacke baut was ja wichtig ist check dass dieses tool ja auch max
wie heißt das lied moment sage ich dir ich versuche es gerade rauszukriegen in
dem stream ja
isa without you schickt ihr den link das läuft gerade das ist nun ein radio auf
youtube ich kann den link nicht checken weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin das läuft
gerade
ist beim nicht gut für die cpu doch prime ist super
prime macht hitze ohne ende so was kann denn dieses komische tool hier
eigentlich noch das gucken wir uns jetzt mal kurz an basic tuning ja ja intel
nervt nicht
es ist jetzt für die nukes hier oder was
das ist das ist quasi auto auf alle auf oberkloppen von intel
bin ich mal gespannt ob es funktioniert ich dachte du hörst metal ja mache ich
auch aber metal im hintergrund ist auf dauer zu anstrengen aber weil du es
bist wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind saman was haben wir hier noch so
metal mäßiges zu bieten was kann man da jetzt noch machen
aber mal so was ja
so
muss es aber auch nicht
The first man I killed was the Earth's right-hand man
When he came to take over
I ran as fast as I could
Straight through his house
And the night that night
I watched him run
I think I'm a bit too quiet now
After the Vikings are at the start
And I'm a bit too quiet now
And the night that night
I watched him run
Was gut Nilsson, so ich mach die Musik mal wieder leiser, es muss jetzt einmal eine Rolle
sein. So, ich bin mal gespannt ob das Ding jetzt irgendwas anzeigt.
Was ich halt merkwürdig finde, weil wir haben ein Offset im Bios eingestellt, wir haben ein
Offset von 0,1 glaube ich. Probieren wir gleich mal aus. Gucken wir erst mal was in diesem
Werk hier jetzt rauskommt. Was war denn das hier gerade? Habe ich Prime aus? Nicht dass
das parallel jetzt läuft. Ja jetzt haben wir das gleiche Ergebnis wie vorher. Keine Ahnung
was das ist. Ich finde das Tool gefällt mir hier von Intel. Das ist besser als im Bios
klicken. Und da steht auch was, was die einzelnen Optionen machen. Keine Ahnung was das macht.
Okay machen wir hier mal ein Offset. Mal wieder mal ein Offset. Was hatten wir hier 70 oder
85? Man kann nur Adaptive einstellen. Default. So was kann man hier sonst noch machen? Sonst
kann man ja auch einstellen. Das ist das Intel Extreme Tuning Utility. Da muss jetzt auch
was drin sein. Ach. Damn. Ein bisschen chilligere Musik an.
So und nun? Was? Also dieses Intel Tool ist, also vom UI ist das eines der hässlichsten
Programme die ich je gesehen habe. Muss ich jetzt mal echt sagen. Das sieht einfach nur
hässlich aus und ist total wild zu bedienen. So was sehe ich denn jetzt? Max 4,8 habe ich
gerade eingestellt. Spannung. Wie viel Spannung hat das Ding jetzt? Wo steht denn das jetzt?
Mal mal Stress Test. Start. Und wo sieht man jetzt wie viel? Wie viel das hat? Was sind
das hier alles für Zahlen? Okay, wir gucken mal wieder hier rein. Was, was ziehen wir
denn? Wir ziehen mehr. Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, dass dieses Setting im BIOS überhaupt
nicht greift. Weil das haben wir im BIOS auch gerade eingestellt. Jetzt wird es aber langsam
ungesund hier. Das haben wir im BIOS auch eingestellt und das hat überhaupt nicht gezogen
so richtig. Wir machen das nochmal in Prime auf. Vielleicht macht auch das BIOS komische
Dinge. Okay, Prime wird schonmal wieder ordentlich warm. Das ist ordentlich hier. Der zieht gut.
Ich glaube, dieses Intel-Tool muss ich mir nochmal in Ruhe angucken. Ich starte den Rechner
nochmal neu und im BIOS stelle ich mal den ganzen Krempel auf Default wieder und dann
machen wir das mal über dieses Intel-Tool. Auto. Auto. Hat sonst noch irgendwas umgestellt?
Nee, Voltage. Auto. Speicher die BIOS-Settings vorher. Nee, das kriege ich aus dem Kopf hin.
Deshalb habe ich sie im Stream gespeichert. Keine Ahnung, warum das... Vielleicht macht
das wirklich das BIOS, weil wenn es die Spannung nicht erhöht hat, das BIOS, obwohl wir es
eingetragen haben, dann ist kein Wunder, dass das Scheiß dann funktioniert. Ich accreere.
Bam. Hat sonst noch irgendwas hochgestellt? Ich glaube, mehr hatten wir eben auch nicht
umgestellt. So, stellen wir das mal alles gleich ein.
Jetzt ist die Musik ein bisschen laut. So. Probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Mal nochmal den Prime an. Da geht er ab, der Prime. Wie viel ziehen wir jetzt? Hä? Da
sind doch jetzt die gleichen Settings wie vorher. Warum sind die gleichen Settings
immer jetzt komplett anders? Hä? What? Verstehe ich nicht. Oh, Rechner ist abgekackt. RIP.
Hallo, Rechner, neu starten. Wie sieht es aus? Blue Screen im Stream, das ist der vierte
oder so. Ich muss mal resetten. Naja, also zumindest wissen wir, dass die CPU verdammt
warm wird. Das können wir aus dem Steam schon mal mitnehmen. Das wird verdammt warm, das
Teil. Aber ich glaube, das war auch genug rumgebastelt für heute. Ich lasse jetzt erstmal
die Fall Settings und ich werde dann wahrscheinlich morgen mit dem Intel Tool noch ein bisschen
rumbasteln, weil es ist schon angenehmer, das aus dem Windows rauszumachen. Aus dem
Windows raus, als immer rebooten zu müssen und sonst BIOS. Heizung schon ausgeschaltet,
ne? Ich hab die Heizung nur auf zwei. Hier ist tatsächlich erstaunlich warm drinne.
Immer im Arbeitszimmer. Hier ist wirklich erstaunlich warm drinne, für das, dass ich
die Heizung nicht richtig an hab. Ok, Hauptsache, das Intel Tuning Tool startet sich automatisch,
wenn es sein muss. Ethanced Tuning. Warum merkt es sich das eigentlich? Achso, da muss
man erst auf Save klicken. Gucken, ob der jetzt mehr zieht gleich. So. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Ok, der Prozessor cache bleibt auf mal 44. Ok. Saven wir das mal. Lull. So, mehr hatten
So mehr hatten wir vorher auch nicht eingestellt Prime anschmeißen
Kirke wird wieder ordentlich warm stimmt in die Temperatur jetzt da drin überhaupt
Ah, vieler zieht. Sag mal stand da nicht eben noch eine Temperatur? Da! 78
Warum eigentlich nur so wenig? Ach wir haben jetzt das wir haben das das das das das Prime an was
nicht so viel zieht verstehe. Wie viel haben wir jetzt hier oben? Das ist wieder das gleiche
warum zieht er denn jetzt auf einmal so wenig? Ich habe das doch hier oben eindeutig eingestellt
oder nicht? Ich meine jetzt jetzt jetzt würde ich erwarten ändert sich das wenn ich jetzt
auf Apply drücke. Aber da ändert sich nichts. Macht dieses Tool überhaupt irgendwas?
Macht das Tool was? Static Voltage will ich nicht machen Static ist doch
Also irgendwie ist dieses Tuning Tool verbesserungswürdig
ganz viel negativ aufsetzen. Ich soll weniger Spannung geben. Ja jetzt ist es weniger geworden
tatsächlich guck mal. Jetzt ist 1 2 3 2. Jetzt ist 1 2 8. Aber auf was bezieht sich denn dann
bitte schon die 0,1? Wenn nicht auf 0,1? Hä? Was? Ich checke es nicht. Auf was bezieht sich das denn?
Man versteht es nicht. Wieso kein Ryzen? Gaming Performance. Mehr FPS. So mal angenommen ich
mache jetzt hier noch mehr. Geht es dann da hoch? Ne das juckt es einfach nicht. Scheiß drauf soll
er mal einstellen was er will das ist mir vollkommen egal. Juckt mich nicht. Kein Bock. Ich bin zwar
das Intel extrem Tuning Tool aber aber keine Lust. Aber jetzt geht es runter also das es
macht wohl was. IA Offset. Ja stimmt der geht hoch.
Keine Ahnung ich hätte eigentlich erwartet dass das hier auch hoch geht.
Wir können ja mal 1,3 stellen wir das jetzt mal ein.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Sollte sich das hier oben nichts ändern?
Kein Schimmer. So komm. Das funktioniert wenigstens.
Jetzt ist es wieder gefriest. Also ganz ehrlich das Intel Tool checke ich nicht so ganz was das
macht. Das leuchtet mir nicht ein. Checke ich nicht. Naja gut ich kann es ja auch im
BIOS einstellen. Wobei ich finde das merkwürdig. Man hat es bei den BIOS Einstellungen direkt
gesehen. Ich meine wir machen jetzt noch mal CPU-Z oder wie das Ding hieß an. Wir gucken es uns da an.
Dann kann ich eigentlich das hier oben nicht auf Static und Adaptive stellen.
So werfen wir Prime noch mal an. Ich checke nicht was das Intel Tool macht. 1,28 mehr gibt es einfach
nicht. Und selbst wenn ich es jetzt hier auf 1,3 stelle das juckt das Tool nicht. Das juckt die
CPU nicht. Ist ja vollkommen egal. Keine Ahnung. Man weiß es nicht. Eigentlich sollte das jetzt
hoch gehen. Achso weil ich beides gesetzt habe. Er erinnert sich trotzdem nichts. Es sollte jetzt
quasi 1,33 haben und es bleibt bei 1,28. Intel Tools in 2K17R. Aber er macht auf jeden Fall was.
Das sieht man. Weil wenn ich jetzt hier wieder auf die Fall stelle. Oder hier auf 0. Dann geht
er hier runter. Aber selbst wenn ich das jetzt hier irgendwie keine Ahnung auf 1,5 stelle. Das juckt
nicht. Vielleicht ist das Maximum oder so. Aber wenn ich es übers BIOS mache geht es doch auch
mehr. Also wenn ich es übers BIOS mache geht es mehr.
Keine Ahnung. Mach mal 0,5. Minus 0,5. Ja das mache ich mal. Ich habe doch bei Graphics
überhaupt nichts umgestellt. Hallo kannst du dich einfach auf die Fall lassen?
Ja das geht. Weniger geht. Das Intel Tool will einfach nicht dass ich mehr mache. Das
Intel Tool hat kein Bock dass ich mehr mache. Ich darf über das Intel Tool nicht mehr machen.
Das ist aber echt doof. Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Warum sollte ich über das
Intel Tool nicht mehr machen dürfen? Nee andere wollten. Wozu? Da kackts ab irgendwann.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht was das Intel Tool macht. Vielleicht gibt es hier wirklich irgendwelche
Settings wo man sagen muss jawoll ich möchte. Nee nee das will ich nicht ändern. Ich könnte
das Ganze mal auf Max performen. Das sind aber die Windows Settings.
Nee nee das ist kein Anzeige Bug. Das stimmt das zeigen andere Tools auch an. Keine Ahnung
was das hat. Vor allem warum Minus 40 das habe ich überhaupt nicht eingestellt. Ja da
bin ich jetzt leider überfragt. Wir können auch mal kurz hier Google befragen. Danach
gehe ich dann auch off. Führt mal erstmal nichts zu.
Wir gucken jetzt nochmal die
was die anderen so hatten. Ah nee keine Ahnung. Da probiere ich mal morgen weiter. Keine Ahnung
warum das Intel Tool nicht mehr macht. Was hat er beim Overclocken die CPU geeidelt?
Nee CPU eidet nicht. CPU ist gerade voll ausgelastet. Also das Tool check ich nicht so ganz. Aber
ich werde jetzt Schluss machen und schlafen gehen. Nee das liegt nicht an der 100% Auslastung.
Das hatte ich ja vorher auch schon. Ich werde jetzt pennen gehen und da sehen wir uns vielleicht
morgen. Ich bin müde. Machts gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Tschüss.